please standby for realtime
captions... Test.
>> Please let me know if you
can hear me right now.
>> STUDENT: I can
hear you!
>> Okay. Awesome. This is
working right.  That's great.
And I got you connected to the
monitor.  I think it's like, ten
minutes...
we're basically just waiting.
We're running late, so you can
make a call when you're ready.
It's supposed to start at 11:10.
captions...
Please
.
for
realtime
.
. .
.              1
.
Live Captions by:
@smiley845 with @whitecoatcapxg
>> Hey!
How's everyone doing?
[ Applause ]
so, so, so quiet, I feel.  How
is everyone doing?
[ Cheers and Applause ]
That's better.  That's how loud
you should be when someone comes
up here on stage, especially our
next speaker.  His name is
David.  He comes from Microsoft.
He's very passionate about open
source.  Loves talking about
web-based technologies,
JavaScript, CSS, and he is going
to talk to us about simplifying
complex UIs.  Who here works on
apps and thinks that they've
gone like, you know, bananas,
and it's way too complex for
them to
handle? Me included.  It can go
into unbelievable complex
things.  I don't know what a
finite automa statechart is, but
we will find out.  Here is David
to talk to us about complex UIs.
[ Applause ]
>> DAVID: Thank you. Is this
on? Can you all
hear me? All right.  There we
go! All right.
So, yeah.  My talk is
simplifying, though I would have
liked to see a talk titled
simplifying complex talk titles
with fewer words.  I know what
you might be thinking right now.
The react API, a little scary?
There's a good book in order to
understand how to best work with
it, and it's doing
whatever Danny says to do.  The
second half of this talk is
exactly what I'm talking about
today, except in the more
general sense.
I want to talk about it,
though.  Not in the context of
React or you or angular or any
of the last frameworks that came
out last week.  But I want to
talk about it in a
framework-less context.  This is
an idea that doesn't just apply
to any framework or no framework
in general, but really any
programming language as well.
We can see how it could help us
simplify our UIs.  So I'm a
pianist, and I have been playing
for about 20 years.  This is the
approach that I take to software
development.  I made the analogy
that if software is music, then
developers are composers.  We're
taking that music, and we're
composing it in a way that is
applicable to any language or
any platform.  And we do so in a
variety of ways.  However,
music's interesting, because
with music, you have music
notation, which you just saw
there.  Let's go back and see
it.  So this stuff right here.
This music notation is hundreds
and hundreds of years old.
However, the exact same notation
is used today to represent music
from classical, romantic,
whatever the hell Bjork is.  You
can give a musician who
understands how to read sheet
music, and they will be able to
play it.  And this works for all
instruments, and you know, all
musicians of all levels.  So I
was wondering, what is the music
notation of user interfaces?
What do all user interfaces have
in common, and how can we
represent that
declaratively?
So when we're working with
software, we usually deal with
APIs.  Good APIs have three main
qualities.  They're well
documented.  You can read the
documentation and understand
exactly what's happening with
the API.  They are very
predictable.  The API is going
to work the exact same way every
time.  And they're also
testable.  You can test against
an API.  They provide mocks for
you or have a test database or
something like that.  So user
interfaces, though? User
interfaces are really complex.
I mean, does anyone find
developing user interfaces easy?
Those of you watching online, no
one raised their hand, which is
good, because I would have
called them out if they did.  We
have to deal with something
called a human API.  That's all
of you, all of our clients,
everyone we work with.  Human
API is undocumented or
unpredictable, and we're
untestable.  And we're also
extremely buggy.  If you don't
believe me, turn on an American
news network, and you'll see
proof of that.  So I work for
Microsoft.  By the way, I'm not
relating Microsoft to any of
this terrible API stuff, I
promise.  And at Microsoft, we
have more than 50,000 software
engineers throughout the world,
and at least 7 designers, I'm
sure.
[ Laughter ]
And we also serve one and a half
billion customers.  I think this
is just for windows.  It might
be more than that.  When we're
developing user interfaces for
1.5 billion people, we have to
imagine all the different ways a
user could use the user
interface.  And you know, this
is different cultures and
languages.  You wonder why
diversity is so important in
tech? We have to reach the 1.5
billion people.  So we don't
develop software for just one
person.  However, when we're
developing software with just
the happy path in mind, that's
essentially what we're doing.
We're assuming that there's this
ideal user who's using our
applications in the exact way
that we want them to.  But this
never
happens.
We're going to take a look
at the code example, but I don't
want you to read too deeply into
the code.  I just want to see if
you relate to this.  We're going
to create a sample F where we
query the flickr API and then
the results.  Similar to what
Dan was doing with movies in his
last talk.  So it's pretty
simple right? We do a fetch.
Then when we get the data, we
show it.  Are there any bugs
here? Are we done? Well...
Let's say the data takes a
long time to load.  Okay.  So
now we have to set this loading
flag, loading is true.  And once
we finish loading data, then we
have to set loading to false.
Are we done? No.  What if we
have an error.  Well, we have to
hide the loading screen, show
the error, right? But, are we
home free yet? No.  Because, we
also have to make sure that we
clear the error once we try to
search again.  As you can see,
the complexity is getting bigger
and bigger.  Now my onserve to
vent handler is getting
extremely huge.  I'm sure many
of you can relate to this code.
Many of you will say yeah, some
of my code looks like that.
Sure.  What if your boss comes
to you and says we want the use
tore be able to cancel the
search, because, you know,
sometimes it takes too
long.
Sometimes they want to search
for something else.  That logic
gets crazier.  I don't know if
you can read that.  I'll zoom in
for you.  But there's a lot of
complexity in just one event
handler.  You might know this as
spaghetti code, where our code
quickly gets unmanageable.  Some
of you might see your engineers
and think I don't do spaghetti
code.  All of my code is modular
and layered and separation of
concerns.  You might not write
spaghetti code, but you might
write lasagne code, which is
spaghetti code in layers.  This
is called the bottom-up
approach.  That approach is
whenever you have an event like
onclick or on change, you do all
of the logic in that event.  And
that can refer to so many
different actions, and some of
those actions might change the
states.  But you have to choose
which actions are executed,
otherwise you might edit the
state in a wrong way, and you
have to ad if statements.
There's a lot of downsides to
this.  This bottom-up code is
difficult to test.  All the
application logic lives in your
mind.  So when you're writing
your tests, you have to output
it from the developer's mind on
to the tests.  And it makes it
really hard to work with other
developers.  The code is
difficult to understand.  The
code that I just showed you for
showing and hiding the gallery,
if you were to try to parse that
as a brand-new developer working
on the project, you would find
it really difficult to do so.
The code will contain bugs, for
sure, because there's going to
be edge cases that you might not
have considered.  It will also
be difficult to enhance, just
like we've seen with
cancellation.  And features,
such as cancellation, make the
code work.  They explode the
potential possible states and
actions that could happen in
your application.
Here's an intuition for
moving forward.  We have a
realization that UI components
are not independent.  We have
frameworks that they isolate
components and say these
components fit in their nice
little box, and we can stick
them in the page
anywhere.
Everything they see on the
screen is in the exact same
context, and we have to
coordinate from components to
component.  So another
realization is that actions,
which is what happens when you
do an event, are based both on
the events executed, and the
current state of
the context.
And it's also that this event
action paradigm is too simple to
represent all the possible
states our app can be in.
So, what's
the solution?
Standard statecharts.  I know a
lot of you may have heard these
before or studied them in
school.  Even though you might
know what these are, you
probably haven't applied them to
user interfaces and actual
software.  So, looking up
material for this could be a
little complicated.  I'm a
visual person, and I'm going to
do it in a very
visual way.
First you have an initial state.
Then you have a finite number of
states, which represents the
states that the app could be in.
When an app is in one state, it
can't be in the other state at
the same time.  You have a
finite number of events, such as
fetching, resolving, or
rejecting a promise.  You have a
mapping from state to state
based on these events.  So for
example, when you're fetching a
promise and it resolves, you go
to the fulfilled state.  And
same way with reject and
rejected state.  And you have a
finite number of final states.
User interfaces can be
continuous.  We could keep using
them.  It doesn't say we're
done, so go uninstall Instagram
because you're not going to need
it.  If you go to this site,
it's going to say promises are
just a state machine.  That
should give you a big clue with
what we're working with here.
So the original app that I
showed you, the gallery app can
be modelled as the state machine
right here.  So we start in the
idle state, and then we go to
search.  Then we're in the
searching state.  If we try to
search again, it loops back.
It's like hold on.  We're
already searching.  We can
either resolve or reject the
search results.  And from those
two states, we could
search again.  This is clearly
seen by the arrows going from
success or failure back to
searching again.
So, the machine that -- the
state machine that I envision
looks sort of like this.  It's a
JSON object.  I like JSON better
than blackbox functions because
you can enumerate all the
possible states and actions and
be able to transition from one
to the other with nice, simple
function right here.  For
example, if we're in the
searching state, and I get a
resolve, then I just look it up
in this JSON object.  This
searching,
on resolve, success.
In type script, it's a record.
I guess it's the same in C#.  In
PHP, they call for help.  I
don't know.  So here's an
example of what I just showed
you.  If I were to search for
iceland -- let's search for
goats first.  Let's say I don't
want to search for goats.  I'll
just cancel that.  Let's search
for Iceland
instead.  When we do the event
of selecting a photo, we have a
state transition that goes from
gallery to photo.  We can exit
that, search again, cancel,
search.  Let's cancel that.
Iceland.  And so you see it goes
from state to state, and no
matter how many times I try to
break this app, it's not going
to deviate from this state
machine that I have here.  And
you see there was a few extra
things such as done searching,
actions over here.  When I'm
update the items? We're going to
discuss that in a little further
detail.  And also this is part
of an article that I wrote which
gives an introduction to finite
state machines.
So I use visual studio
share.  I work on it and I also
have to use it.  It's called dog
fooding.  Anyway... and this is
sort of what it looks like.  And
so, I don't know if we have
Sarah and Burke in here.  Here's
Burke right now.  You can think
of it as Google docs for
collaborative coding.  It's in
preview in Microsoft.  And I
have no control over what
they're typing, and they're
typing this in realtime.  With
this live share, we can
collaboratively code in the
exact same document at the same
time.  These are a complex
series of events that are
happening at the same time, and
so we have to manage all of
these possible events and all
the possible states that this
could be in.  I have no idea...
Oh God.  Good luck breaking
the demo.  It probably will,
though.  Ha ha.  Anyway! I'm
going to end this before it gets
too crazy...
One of the big things I have to
work on in liveshare is this
whole sign-in flow.  You would
think that signing in is easy
and, you know, signing in,
signing out, all of that.  But
it's actually not.  Once you
start drawing it out, it becomes
a lot more complex.  So for
example, there could be a
sign-in failure.  You know,
especially from Iceland.  I'm so
glad that worked in Iceland.
All of our servers are based in
the United States.  So when you
have a sign-in success, then you
go to the signin state.  From
there you could go do two
things.  You could either share
a session or join a session.  So
what I did was a couple months
back, I refactored this part of
the app so that it uses an
explicit state machine just like
this.  We were getting a lot of
bugs.  We were saying what if
we're in the middle of sharing
and the user signs out? What if
we join the session, and then we
decide to share a session at the
same time? That shouldn't be
allowed.  We had all of these
if/else and switch statements,
so I decided there has to be a
better way.  I did the simpl
JSON object approach.  The state
machine that I set up? It was
very easy to add telemetry to
it.  I added telemetry, and I
get this nice visual showing
exactly the frequency of how
users go from state to state.
So you could see obviously, most
of the users go through this
initializing and then signing in
state, and then you could either
externally sign in, or you could
sign out.  And then you could
see that users tend to go to
either joining or sharing, you
know? At about the same
frequency.  And yeah.  So it
clearly shows, too, how many
users go to the error state and
how many users go to the success
state for each of these states
as well.  Now, these are very
powerful insights.  Because
while telemetry will only tell
you an atomic bit of data, here
is telemetry that tells you the
entire user flow of what's
happening.  We could limit this
to user and be able to see a
nice path of what the user
actually did in the app.  So
it's sort of like, you know,
like the funnel diagrams, except
even crazier.
We could also use state
machines for integration
testing.  And so this gets a
little bit into graph theory, so
bear with me a little bit.
Here we would be using a
shortest path algorithm.  You
could choose your favorite one.
It sounds like an
Icelandic name.
Any of these formulas for
finding the shortest path.  And
so, for those who don't know,
the shortest path is just going
from one state to the other with
the minimal cost.  So you could
imagine each of these arrows
have a wait.  And so you just
want to minimize, you know, how
long it takes to get from one
path to the other.  Sort of like
in Google maps, finding the
shortest ETA from one point to
the other.  So analytics would
provide these waits.  And this
heaped represents all the happy
paths a user could take.  If we
want a user to, let's say, share
a session, and get to the shared
state, we would imagine the user
going from signed in to sharing
to shared.  Just that simple.
These could be automatically
generated from the JSON
structure just like this.  But,
remember, we're not just dealing
with the happy paths.  So, we
would do a death first search
algorithm to find all the other
paths a user could take.  Some
of you might be thinking these
algorithm things, I didn't think
I would need them.  You sort of
do; they're really
helpful.  And so, these
represent all the possible user
flows.  You can imagine a user
getting from state A to state C
might not take the easiest
route.  They might take a longer
route to get all the way to C.
And it reveals all the edge
cases.
When you model every single
possible state with every single
possible action, and you get all
of these flows, you're going to
basically have 100,000% test
coverage for anything that could
possibly happen in your app.
And of course these could all be
automatically generated.  I
caution against this, because
you would be generating
integration tests -- it would
generate a lot of integration
tests, which isn't necessarily a
bad thing, but when you're doing
continuous integration, you
don't want your tests to take
four hours long.
It makes software bugs
visually clear by drawing a map
and putting them on the diagram.
You can see when I do this
event, I'm going to the wrong
state.  Or maybe I have an
unhandled event, which does
nothing.  Or maybe I have a
missing transition.  That's
shown here, too.  For example,
Dan was showing the example
where when you click a movie, it
just waits and waits, and then
you get the next movie, and
there's no loading state.  You
can clearly see that in the
state transition diagram.  And
also, my favorite, race
conditions.  These are just made
completely nil and void with
state machines, because you
explicitly say, when I get this
event, I go to this state.  If I
get another event after that
that I don't care about, it's
not going to cause a race
condition, because I will ignore
that event.  And that's what
state machines can help with.
Now I want to talk about
Harold statecharts.  This could
go on for hours and hours,
because there's so much
information here.  I'm going to
give an overview of what these
are and how these extend state
machines in order to improve the
way we look at user interfaces.
Because, user interfaces can get
complex, and finite state
machines might not solve
everything.  So with
statecharts, they are similar to
state machines.  They are an
extension of it.  Except we can
have actions with Harel
statecharts, too.  They actually
do things to the state and the
app.  We can have guards which
prevent states from going from
one to the other if something
doesn't match the condition.  If
I'm trying to search for
something, and the user didn't
give me a search query, then I'm
not going to transition to the
next state.  That could be
declaratively modelled as well.
There's the idea of nested
states.  This is parallel
states.  It is not concurrent
states where an app can be in
two states at the same time.
It's more a way of simplifying
the number of states you have so
your state machine doesn't look
all crazy.  And also, history,
which is a very common feature
that many users would want in
order to go back to their safe
state.  So I created this
library called X states which
models finite state machines and
statecharts in a declarative
way, so that all you would have
to do is use this JSON structure
to model your state machine, and
then you would get the next
state by calling transition on
the current state and the
action.  It's functional, and
it's going to work in any
framework or no framework at
all.  It also has the notion of
actions, so it will return you
an object telling you, these are
the next actions that you're
going to take once you
transition to a state.  It also
has guards, so you could pass in
some external state, and it will
validate against that external
state and say, Okay, this
condition is met.  So you go on
to the next state.  It also has
hierarchy so you can represent
and compose machines easily.  It
has
orthogonality so you can
represent parallel states and
also represent remembered
states.  If you're doing a
payment flow and you're asking
for cash or card, the user can
switch between them, and the
user gets to the review page.
You want to remember if the user
chose cash or card.  So you go
to method.history, and it would
remember that.  And this is a
purely functional, no side
effect type of thing.  And so
you can imagine the applications
of where you could apply this.
One example of where you would
use orthoganal states is this
example.  Say you have bold,
italic, or underline.  A user
can use all or none of them, and
it's represented by all of these
eight states.  And you can
imagine if we add more options
such as align left, align
center, justify, it's going to
explode into even more states.
With orthogonal statecharts, we
just have this succinct
representation of these possible
states, so that we know we can
go from bold on to after,
italics on to off, and same way
with underline, and we can
represent all of those at the
same time.  And also, hierarchy
helps to reduce the number of
arrows that you have in your
finite state machine.  So for
example, both the success and
failure states, we could search
again and go back to the
searching state.  We could
simplify this by just nesting
them in a single state, the
search state.  This is fully
supported by X state, and yeah.
So, you could imagine how this
would simplify just really
complex state machines.  So, I
released X state about six
months ago at React rally, and
since then, there has been a lot
of development and a lot of
people actually using it to make
projects such as React automa
and others.  And pretty soon,
I'm going to be releasing
another version, minor version.
Don't worry; nothing crazy, of
Xstate where we improved the
user
ergonomics.  It's full SCXML.
It's not sexy.  Code is not sexy
at all.  A
Reactive interpreter,
visualization interpreter, and a
lot more examples.
In order to show you what
I'm talking about, here is an
example of a visualization tool.
That same JSON object that you
passed into xstate and the same
one I used for my gallery app,
this is one example of where you
would
use this.  My initial state is
start, and I can hover over this
search action, and go to this
state.  Then I could see the
possible different actions --
sorry, events that I could take
from this state.  So let's say I
have a search success.  And so,
I go into the gallery view.  And
then I choose to search again,
or I could select a
photo.  So, I can visually see
what's happening in my state
machine by pasting in that JSON
object.  That's hard to do with
just a function, so that's why I
decided to do it in a more
declarative way.  I'm going to
be releasing this soon.
I want you all to enjoy the rest
of the conference before I
release it, so you can have time
to play with it afterwards.
That's my excuse, at least.
It's not out yet.
Now, it would be, you know, sort
of remiss of me to not talk
about sort of the downsides of
state machines and statecharts,
but the truth is that you all
are already creating finite
state machines and statecharts
in your app already, and you
don't even know it.  However,
the ones that you're creating
are implicit.  They're full of
bugs.  They're incomplete.  And
that's just the nature of
how we code.  So the advantage
of finite state machines and
modeling them in a very explicit
way is that you reduce a lot of
complexity up front just by
getting rid of your if/else
statements and getting rid of
your switch statements and
having a direct mapping.
However, that quickly explodes
into many, many different
states.  So statecharts help
manage that with a little higher
complexity cost up front.  But
in the long run, you will see it
will be very easy to add
features, remove features, and
handle different actions and
different possible modes of your
application.
So, of course, there's a lot of
advantages to using statecharts,
and the ones I am going to quote
are not actually from me.
They're from NASA.  A few years
ago, NASA had to send this
little vehicle right here all
the way to Mars.  And they did
so using statecharts.  So the
advantages that they said was,
first of all, there's visualized
modeling.  So you could both
model and examine the model of a
state chart using visual tools.
You get these precise diagrams
that tell you exactly what's
going to happen when certain
conditions are met, when you're
in a certain state, and this
event happens.  When you're
sending something to Mars, you
can't exactly just send it there
and hope that it work works,
right? You have to be absolutely
sure that your billion dollar
project is going to handle every
single possible state.  And so
they also use state charts for
automatic code generation.  I'm
not a fan, but you could see how
it could be beneficial.  Also,
comprehensive test coverage.  By
using state charts, they were
able to generate just all of
these integration tests where
they could test each and every
one, and ensure that every
single state was being hit, and
every single possible action or
event was being handled.  Also,
you know, being on a big
project, you have a lot of
requirement changes.  We want to
add this to the rover.  We want
to remove this functionality.
We want to change the way this
works.  And when you're working
on a big project, and you have
these late breaking requirement
changes, then things can get
really stressful.  With state
charts, since you could clearly
see the full flow of your
application, you could easily
add and remove features without
worrying what's going to break,
what's going to change, what's
going to be affected.  So there
are some disadvantages as well.
And the disadvantage is that
my screen just went black.  I
guess that means there are no
disadvantages.  Ha ha.
Anyway...
Since the rest of my slides are
forked, I want to show you this
real quick.  I gave a talk about
one and a half years ago.
It was at
JSConf Iceland.  This is where I
saw the primary use case for
using state machines and
statecharts.  There was this
really complex UI design that I
really wanted to model, and I
found it pretty difficult
without using an explicit state
machine or state chart.  So what
I'm doing here, there's three
different states.  This one.
This one.  And there's different
actions as well.  So
the user could pan right, but
just a little bit.  So I handle
that as a transition from going
to state A, back to state A if
they didn't move far enough.  Of
course, if they move far enough,
it goes to the next state
successfully.  And also, it
handles, like, if I'm going up,
and I decide to go left and
right, it's not going to do
anything, because we're already
going up and down.  So it knows
when this event happens, don't
try to go to a different state,
because we're already
transitioning to one state.
I also wanted to mention two
very good resources.
The first one is on
spectrum.oi/statecharts.  This
is a community where we talk
about statecharts, their
possible applications, and how
they're used everywhere.
Statecharts are nothing new.
They're invented by David Harel
in 1987, which is what? 30 years
ago? This is not cutting-edge
stuff.  If people are asking why
aren't we using statecharts
everywhere now? Well, the thing
is, they are in embedded systems
or systems programming.  People
do use statecharts in order to
model their applications.  We
don't, quite yet, but I think
it's about time that we catch up
to it.  And so, Eric Mogansen
made a wonderful resource called
the unfinished world of
statecharts.  Over here, if you
want to learn more information,
there's a well
wealth of
information here.  I really want
to
encourage you to revisit your
application and the way you
think about things, and actually
try to visualize things.  You
will see that by visualizing
your application, all of its
possible states, all the events
that could happen, that you're
going to have a clearer
representation of the possible
bugs, the possible features that
you might have, the user
improvements, and everything
else.  So I want to thank you
all for having me.
Unfortunately, I can't show you
my last slide, because it's not
working, but thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> That was so awesome! I
have a question for you.  I
thought it was really
interesting, and I also want to
apply this to what I do in
working with UIs.  Do I have to
completely refactor my app so I
can get the advantages of what
you just talked about with
finite state machines?
>> DAVID: That's a really
good question.  With Redux, you
have to pull everything out, but
with statecharts, you don't.
Statecharts can't model
absolutely everything, and
neither can finite state
machines.  So what you could do
is you could write a separate
finite state machine that
represents your app, use that to
create tests, and once you see
all the tests are passing, then
you slowly start moving it in.
You can use finite state
machines for things as small as,
should this button be disabled?
And then you stick it in there,
have your app grow, and use
state machines everywhere.
>> That's awesome. Thank you
so much.  That's actually a
really good transition into the
next talk.  It's going to be
from Will.  He's coming from
Colorado.  He's passionate about
open source software as well,
organizing events and meet-ups.
Is Will around?
All right! Seems like Will's not
here?
>> Let's take a bit of a break
while we wait for the next talk.
Thank you.
>> Will is here, so, we're
>> Will is here, so, we're going
to get started
really soon.  I'm going to talk
about Will and Will's talk while
he sets up.  He's a front-end
engineer, co-organizes the React
Denver meet-up.  He loves
sharing what he can, organizing
events, mentoring others.  And
he says he lives on a healthy
diet of diet coke and
ice cream.
That sounds healthy.  And he
will be testing using a tool
called Cyprus.  And it's for
end-to-end testing.  Now we
discussed complex UIs, and now
it's time to test the complex
UIs that we just created.
Live Captions by:
@smiley845 with @whitecoatcapxg
>> WILL: Thanks! Almost. One
second.  Thank you.
Is it actually presenting okay?
>> I think it looks great
from this  end.  Anyway, give it
up for Will Klein!
[ Applause ]
>> WILL: Oh my gosh, I think
it works! Cool! Okay.  Whoo!
So, I've got a talk about
end-to-end testing, and why the
game has changed.  I actually
have a little story to share as
well that's kind of personal,
but it means a lot to be
here today.  My name is Will,
and this is my wife, Diane.
This is us on Amelia island.  It
was a really great time.  I
appreciated that JSConf welcomed
us and our family.  I appreciate
that that tradition has
continued here today.  I had a
question at the time that I was
trying to figure out the answer
to.  How do you it's your front
end? I think we've got answers
about how to test our unit
tests, how to test our
functions, our classes, and our
UI components in isolation.  I
think it becomes more difficult
when we try to integrate all of
these things and put it all
together.  A lot can go wrong,
whether it's our UI or web APIs
or our back-end or database or
even our deployments.  When you
put those things together,
anything can break down, and we
can have all the unit tests in
the world, and they won't help
us in most cases.  So the type
of tests to emphasize this are
called end-to-end tests, from
one end all the way back.  I had
a lot of great conversations at
the conference.  Sorry.  Move my
mouse off.  I had a lot of great
conversations, but one stuck
out.  I
met this person Nicholas Boll,
and he talked to me for hours.
His wife was at the conference
and she was quickly becoming
friends with my wife while
hanging out and talking about
testing.  We talked about the
tests his team had written.
They had thousands and thousands
of unit tests.  Lots and lots of
integration tests, and maybe a
thousand or so end-to-end tests.
They were testing an Enterprise
app, which is an app that does
way too many things.  I was so
impressed with all the things
they had to say about their
stack and tools and all the
effort they put in that I
applied to work at his company.
We moved to Colorado and joined
his team.  He and his wife
helped us off the moving truck,
helped us settle in and invited
us in for the holidays.  Now we
hang out so much together today.
So when I joined this team,
I found they were using a tool
that I was actually quite
familiar with,
se  Selenium.  It lets us test
apps from the point of view of
the browser.  It's a little old,
but it's done a lot of wonderful
things and let us do things that
we otherwise might not be able
to do.  It's go this java
service that just listens for
commands.  And you write test
code in any language, actually,
and more often than not, not
JavaScript.  And that language
would usually use a library to
speak the language of Selenium.
It sends the command to the
service, and the service would
cue the commands and try to send
them to any given browsers, real
browsers.  There was a number of
different abstractions and
interfaces where things could go
wrong.  It could be that your
test code has an issue, or
you're using the API different.
And all the different APIs work
with Selenium, and they all work
with JavaScript.  They are all
different.  They could have
issues or you could use them
differently.  They are sending
command drivers to the browser,
and the drivers could have bugs.
There are so many ways for this
to have bugs just with this
architecture.
So the greatest complexity
of all is our app.  I find that
as we write modern JavaScript
apps, we're doing a lot of
things now in the browser.
We're making the different API
calls from the page loads.
Those come back in different
timings, different orders
sometimes.  That can cause just
different behaviors in our front
end.  When the user interacts
with our UI, that makes more
calls.  More things happen.  All
these things happen
asynchronously.  So we are
rendering.  It could finish at
any time, and we don't really
necessarily know when it is, at
least from our test code's point
of view.  As humans, it's
intuitive to us.  But when we
run our test code, it does
exactly what we tell it to.  If
it clicks a button and starts to
rerender, and we try to do the
next thing, we need to be
careful about knowing that it
finished rendering, or we might
get something unexpected.
So, the greater problem of
all is when we take the Selenium
architecture and combine it with
the complexity of our apps.
It's really a recipe for frees
frustration.  We run a commit,
push it to the build, and
sometimes it would fail, usually
in an end-to-end test.  We would
run that build again, because it
was a test that shouldn't have
broken anything.  And it would
pass.  We would see this over
and over again, where different
commits randomly fail different
tests.  We call this flakeyness.
The problem might be something
with the Selenium architecture.
Often it was a combination of
that and the complexity of our
app working in different
performance characteristics.
Particularly when we're on build
environments, they're
virtualized, things would slow
down.  Anything could make it
work a little slower in one part
of the stack at any given time,
and something would fail.  We
had a build job that would just
run all the tests, and it would
flush out dozens and dozens of
tests that just failed a lot.
Even with that, we just kept
tripping over this issue over
and over again.  Tests that
would fail once in a while.  Why
do we keep doing this? Well,
these tests we found to be
extremely valuable.  You can
have all the unit tests in the
world, but if everything
integrates and something breaks
down, you're going to have a
really bad time.  And worst of
all, your user is going to have
a bad time.  At the end of the
day, everything you do is about
building a user experience,
building values so somebody can
do their job or that part of
their job, or make that one
thing easier that gives them joy
and makes them happier or more
productive.  We invested into
making this better, the flakey
finder.  And we tried to make
our tests better in a lot of
ways.  One example, we wrote
some test helpers that would try
a command, and if something
didn't work right, it would
retry it a number of times for a
certain time out.  This is
called an implicit wait, built
into the API, so you don't have
to do that manually in the code.
We also found that it helped to
mock some service once in a
while, mock services to test
large data and certain
scenarios.  Things like that.
Doing that, we wrote some of our
own service mocking libraries to
make that process easier.  We
invested as much as we could
into making the developer
experience of using and running
our tests better.  So we keep
doing it, despite how painful
it was.
So, after a while, I joined
a new time and got Selenium up
and running there.  That went
all right.  Ran into some of the
same issues, and just this past
fall in October, I was consult
consulting on a project.  We had
run into a serious quality
problem.  We didn't have a
dedicated QA team.  As much as
we smoke tested our app on every
single commit, there were always
use cases we missed and we
didn't know what happened.  We
decided to write more tests.  I
pulled the story to write the
end-to-end test.  I pulled out
Selenium, and the first thing I
had to do on my year-old mac
book was install java.  So the
next tool I tried was Cyprus.
And Cyprus was something that I
had actually held off on using
for a while.  It had been closed
source up until May of last
year, and in private beta until
October.  They had built a
company around some of the
premium CI features.  Now that
it's open-sourced, everything
that you need is right up there
on GitHub.  If the team stopped
doing what they're doing, the
community could pick it up and
run with it.  I waited to use
this until it was open and
freely available.  Something
that was MIT licensed and ready
to go.
So I actually used it for maybe
two hours, and I was honestly
blown away.  I was so shocked by
how different and better my
developer experience was that I
wrote a proposal to a conference
after just working on it for a
couple of hours, and here I am.
[ Laughter ]
I have a few downloads that
I will run through to show you
how to install it, set it up,
what some of the tests look
like.  I don't want to get hung
up on the syntax or commands.  I
just want to give you an idea of
what it's like.  The first thing
you do is you MPM install it.
This actually will do a download
from one of their -- from their
website and pull down the right
cypress app.  It will pull down
based on your operating system
and your CPU architecture.
Next you open it.  And the first
time you open it, it kind of
initializes some things and
makes sure it's verified and
it's the right thing and all.
When it runs, there's a pop-up
to say hey, to help get you
started, we put some files in
the file system, and you might
want to take a look at that.
The files are basically
examples.  This is just nice.
There is an example like
fixture.  There's example
plugin.  Custom commands, and an
example spec.  The example spec
is a kitchen sink of all the
different commands you might
want, and gives you a quick
reference.  You can go to their
docs, but it's all right there.
It gives you a little head-start
with what you might want to try
to do.
The nice thing is, it's --
from there, it starts to get
very familiar.  If you've ever
done BDD style tests, the syntax
is going to look very, very
familiar.  Let me make this a
little bigger.  Oh yes.  Cool.
All right.  So this is just part
of a spec file.  And the first
thing is there's this top-level
describe.  We're describing our
app or some view in our app, and
we can have the eaches, and do
things before every test.  And
most commonly will load the
page, load a route on our app.
We can have nested describes in
mocha.  And we can have our
it/shoulds.  It should do a
thing.  It should focus on the
to do field.  And from there we
can start using the cypress API.
We are doing focus, which is
look at what's focused in the
window.  And then it says it
should have the class new to do.
There's something interesting
about the should, and this
whole, you'll see some chaining
here.  There's a reason why hay
the use that style.  The should
has a context of I'm try to do a
should on something that was
focused.  The should will keep
trying until it's true or until
there's a time-out.  This is
nice, because when we first load
our page, the first thing that's
focused might just be the window
or document.  That thing has not
rendered that has that class.
It's going to keep retrying
until it passes.  This permeates
all of their APIs, and having
that context and doing things
more intelligently by nature.
I'll show you one other example.
This is an example that is quite
common where you try to get
something based on selector.
It's using
Jquery under the hood.  And then
we just type in a little thing
we want to do, and another thing
I'll point out is instead of
having to embrace the key codes,
having to know what key code,
they just use enter with curly
braces.  It's nice and
convenient that
way.
From here, I want to show
you what running the test and
debugging the test looks like.
All the other stuff is
relatively familiar to Selenium.
This is where it starts to take
off.  So the first thing is you
can run it headlessly.  By
default, it runs headless
ly.  It is recording by default.
So you can replay the recording
and all the tests, if you want.
Here is where it starts to get
different.  There's an electron
app.  The first thing that
happens when you load the
electron app, there's a yellow
warning that says, Hey, can you
make sure you're running your
web server.  It will check that
when this app electron app runs
to make sure you're running your
web server.  I can't tell you
how many times I forgot to run
my local dev server when I'm
running my test.  It tells you
right away.  And you can also
choose which browser, whatever
version of Chrome or firefox and
Edge and all of that eventually.
I'll get to that.  And then you
run your spec.  From here we get
into the test
runner.  This is running in a
browser, a sandbox browser
environment.  The test runner,
there's our test on the left, a
header on the top that has this
information about what tests
have passed, which have failed,
how long it's been running.  We
can stop and replay it.  There's
a URL preview.
There's a target icon, that's
adomadom a dom selector
playground.
There's view port information at
the top.  On the right is our
app.  This might seem like a
little thing, but just having it
right in the same window is very
convenient.  And there's a very
good reason why they put this
all in the same
window.
So that thing on the left
where our commands and tests are
logged, that's called the
command log.  This thing is
cool.  When we click on anything
in there, expand one of our
tests, we see all the commands
that our test tried to execute.
If we click on any of the
commands, it will jump to that
part of the test.  It takes DOM
snapshots throughout the test.
We can jump around in our test
sequentially or out of order,
and replay the state of our dom
and see what's going on in our
app without having to -- without
much effort.  And you'll see
this thing at the bottom of our
app that says before and after.
Certain have commands such as
before and after.  Typing is one
of them.  If you go to type new
todo, you hit before, you can
see what's going on, and then
click the after and see what was
after the typed command.  This
ability to walk through the dom
snapshots just by click
something a night and day
difference from anything I
experienced with Selenium.  The
workflow I was used to is
setting up a debugger, setting
up a trigger point and hoping to
stop at the right point and
running into default time-outs
and test reloading and all of
the lockouts that were
frustrating.
If you write really good
tests about your app like this,
you can actually sort of
document how your app works.
And a new user or new person on
the team could look at it and
get a good understanding of all
the things it does and how it
behaves and what it looks like.
All of that.
So, let's talk about
debugging, like really
debugging.  The first thing is
when we click on those things in
the test runner, any of those
things we click, they have some
context of there's a DOM element
involved or a network request.
If you click, they get logged in
the console.  Normally I would
have to set a break point and
write the logs.  Just with a
click, we can get that and start
playing with it.
DOM debugging, you can inspect
the state of the DOM in any of
these snapshots.
It's not necessarily replaying
all your different Redux states,
for example, your true app
state.  It's just going based on
the DOM.  I have found in
reality, with an app using React
and Redux, I was interact and
things would sort of work.  And
there are hooks to potentially
do things like inject Redux
state and snapshot that stuff.
I haven't gotten to that yet;
I'm not sure anybody has.  But
there are crazy anyonings --
things we can do.
I found it really awesome that I
only needed to run this one
browser, this one app and this
one debugger to debug my tests
and app code.  This replay is
showing hitting a break point in
my test code here and hitting a
break point in my app code.
And being able to jump between
those two contexts.  I was used
to having a debugger, hopefully
in node and another in the dev
tools for my app, and I would be
bouncing around between the two.
There's this cognitive load that
comes with, which one am I in?
Where am I? Bouncing back and
forth and windows switching and
all of that.  When you start to
take this very challenging thing
that we do every day and you put
it in a single place and make it
that much easier, it starts to
make it
fun again.
I mentioned we had to write
our own implicit waits.  There's
a four-second time-out, which is
plenty.  You can override that.
There's direct access to the
DOM.  In Selenium, everything
was being serialized, so you're
always getting a serialized
version of the DOM.  You're
actually dealing with a DOM
that's in your app from your
test code, and you just have it.
It's just nice.  And there's
service mocking libraries built
in.  They just made it easy to
define things you want to match
on like method or parameter and
have it return fixture data.
It's just rolled up.  That's the
thing overall.  It rolls up all
this tooling that we would
normally be cobbling together
ourselves, sign on for the
request stuff, service mocking,
Jquery, mocha and chai.  It
takes care of all of that for us
so we don't have to select them
ourselves, and it becomes one
cohesive package that is well
documented on their site.
On their blog and docs, they
have tidbits like this.  When
you start to extend the
time-out, which is a common
trap, something didn't work.  It
wasn't ready yet.  So we'll
extend the time-out.  There's a
catch to that, especially if you
do it universally.  There are
things, tidbits that are not
specific to cypress.  There's a
book in here about how to write
good end-to-end tests that could
apply to Selenium or whatever
other tool you want to use.  I
like that.  I like that they're
a little opinionated and they
share these things right in
their docs.  It's nice that they
went
that far.
There are trade-offs.  I
have been talking about how
awesome it is, but I want to
talk about what it lacks.  It's
a new tool, new technology, a
new thing to bring into your
team.  There's always a cost to
that.  I take that very
carefully.  It has a style of
chaining, and I don't like
chaining, but there's a reason
for it.  They like to maintain
the context of what you're doing
so they can intelligently tell
what you're doing next.  They're
up front about their trade-offs.
They have a whole doc dedicated
to this.  They mention permanent
and temporary trade-offs.
Permanent is that it runs in a
single browser tab.  If it opens
other tabs, you will not be able
to test those things in cypress.
They didn't try to support every
browser out of the gate.  They
just chose Chrome-based
browsers.  They are working on
Firefox.  They are fixing issues
on that, squashing some bugs,
and they will have that as soon
as they can.  And I'm sure that
Edge and so forth will be next.
That's something
that is very important.  I would
suggest still having some
Selenium tests just for those
situations that cypress cannot
do.  I find that 99% of the
value of the tests is easily
covered by cypress, making sure
we exercise all the views and
interactions that we care about,
testing each work flow once.
The user wants to do A, B, C.
Test those things.
Testing the UI components at
least once is really important.
They basically re-invented
the wheel, and any time you do
that, you will have your own set
of bugs and challenges.  I think
they tried to not only
They basically re-invented
reinvent Selenium but add a
comprehensive developer
experience on top of it.  That
is crazy.  If I would have ever
met the original author years
ago, I would tell him good luck.
I don't think it's possible.
Don't feel bad if you fail.
Here he is, with what started as
an experiment.
He got it working, and he's
built a team around it.  There's
six full-time devs on
it now.
The open-source community is
growing and others have made
contributions.  There's going to
be bugs and issues.  There's
going to be the trade-offs I
mentioned.  I'm really glad that
they made it anyway.
So I would definitely say when
it comes to end-to-end testing
and our ability to test the user
experiences, the game has
changed.  I would encourage
everyone to not just think about
unit coverages, but user
experience
coverage.  If you're new to
this, do this.  Write a smoke
test.  Test the main work flow.
Do the happy path.  Make sure
that's good.  That is going to
give you 90% of the value.
You're going to cover your build
and deployments and that one
thing that your app is supposed
to do.  From there you can start
to cover more things.  But that
is the one thing that you could
do in maybe a day.  I think I
had -- I think I had the first
app tested in an hour or two,
and I went from
there.
I like to say this, don't
let your users test an app.  If
you're not automating these
things, that's what you're
doing.  You can have a QA team
or smoke testing this yourself
in your own browser, but there's
no way you can catch all the
things that the automated tests
can catch as quickly as they can
catch.  If you do them manually,
what's your dev cycle? These
things can run very quickly and
catch so much
more.
So atlas law.  Any
application that can do
JavaScript eventually will,
right? That's a good thing.  I
was working in visual studio
code, and I thought wow.  I
remember when atom came out.
Before I was using sublime.
Everyone loves sublime.  Or at
least they used to love sublime.
And then atom came out.  And oh,
this is rendering JavaScript in
editor? This is fast and crazy.
And visual studio code? I'm
thinking when I use visual
studio code in atom, I'm using
pluginplugins.  There are
eco-systems of tools, because
they're written in JavaScript,
and things we're familiar with.
With cypress, it's still evolve
evolving.  We're in the early
stages of seeing that eco-system
expand and grow and become
something beyond what the
original authors intended.
I really want to thank the
cypress team.  They did an
amazing job.  They definitely
ran into all the problems that I
experienced with Selenium, and
said they wanted to do better.
And they have.  They've built
something that not only is
written in JavaScript, but tried
to solve the developer
experience and tried to make it
smoother and make it encouraging
for us to write the tests that
are not always easy.  I think
they've done a terrific job.  If
you -- I think their docs are
great.  But if you need more
help than what's in their docs,
check out their GitHub chat.  I
promise you they're nice and
friendly.
I want to finish my personal
story.  This is my family and
Nicholas's family.  We each had
a daughter two years ago.
They're born a month apart.  Our
wives are both expecting our
second this summer.  I really,
really wanted to bring my family
here, but my wife is five months
pregnant and my daughter is two
years old and wants to climb
over everything.  I asked my
wife's doctor if I should, and
she yelled at me.  She said that
would be a very bad idea.  I
miss them very much, but I will
also say that Nicholas and I,
you know, still talk for hours,
and still teaches me new things.
I'm so grateful for having met
them at JSConf five years ago.
Thank you for joining me
today, for wanting to hear about
how to write tests, how to do
this better, about what's
changed.  I hope I have given
you some ideas about that and
about what's happened in our
eco-system, what's happened in
our tooling.  I love talking
about this stuff.  Please come
find me or find me on Twitter
Twitter @willslab.
>> Thank you so much. I find
your story really inspiring.
It's like a story of mentorship
turning into friendship and more
mentorship after that.  We can
all learn something from that.
Really, talk to the people next
to you and get to know their
story and learn from them.
We're all here to learn from one
another.  So a few
announcements.  We do have a
lunch break right now.  We also
do have the diversity panel
happening at 12:15.  Grab your
lunch and join us on the
diversity panel.  It's going to
be fun.  Another thing is that
the SO party passes or tickets
are apparently still available,
so you can still buy them.  And
that's it.  Hope you have a good
lunch.
Live Captions by:
@smiley845 with @whitecoatcapxg.
>> Hey. How's lunch? No
>> Hey. How's lunch? No one's a
fan of lunch? That's like my
favorite time of day.  The lunch
was great.  I love fish and
salmon.  Let's get into our next
round of talks.
[ Applause ]
People from Iceland are shy
or don't feel like clapping? I
don't know how medium works
anymore.  Our next speaker is
coming from London.  She is born
and raised in
San Francisco and is a creative
engineer at Google.  And she
will talk to us about something
that is really cool, in my
opinion.  It's augmented
reality.  I've never played with
it, but it seems like cool
technology.  Please give it up
and help me welcome Raisa up on
the stage.
[ Applause ]
>> RAISA CUEVAS: Hey,
everybody.  I think my mic is
working.  I should have done
this earlier.
All right.  So, first of all,
let's get this on
the screen.  I'm a little
embarrassed about my outfit.
The truth is, I brought a really
nice, stylish shirt to wear
today, but my hotel room didn't
have an iron.  I called them at
7:00 in the morning, and they
took too long to bring it up.  I
was panicking this morning, and
called my boyfriend, and I said
I don't have anything else to
wear.  Maybe I'll go on stage
and look like a
mountineer.  And he said it's
okay.  It's a developer
conference.  And I'm like that's
right.  Let me introduce myself.
My name is Raisa, and I'm a
creative engineer at Google.  We
were looking for ways to use
augmented reality in one of our
marketing campaigns.  I took the
liberty to do the research on my
own and see what's possible.  I
got really excited about the
many years that it has gone
back, and wanted to share with
my team to help them appreciate
what it is today, and do my
actual job of reporting back
what's possible today and
in the future.
So what is possible in
the future? I want to make a
quick disclaimer that all this
research I did was on my own.
It's all public knowledge, and
with that being said, I'm
speaking on behalf of myself and
not on behalf of my company or
any of the organizations I'm a
part of.
So let's step back into
1901.  This is a time before
airplanes, before traditional
color photography that we know,
and nearly a decade before the
first talking motion picture.
Yet, before all of these
technological advances, we had a
visionary author who envisioned
a world in a book called "the
Master Key," and he put on a
pair of spectacles that would
overlay a character marker.  He
is looking around and can judge
a person on a single look.
These were really deep sci-fi
thoughts back in 1901.  I can't
imagine how he could have come
up with the idea.  If the name L
Frank Baum rings a bell, he's
also the author of the wizard of
Oz.
Fast forward to 1968.  We have
built a plane and orbited the
moon.  And we also have the
first head-mounted display.
This was developed by Ivan
Sutherland.  You can see him
spinning around, and all he can
see is a simple wire cube.
After this hard work, you saw a
visionary cube in space.  And
this was a really important
precursor to AR.  As you can
see, there have been so many
advancements with head-mounted
displays these days.  And now
looking at 2018, we have a
rocket orbiting into space with
a car that is out there
floating.  But we also have all
of these advancements in
augmented reality.  Everyone is
talking about it being the next
big thing.  Technologists and
investors alike are speculating
on when this will blow up.
So what's happening? There
is rich history that dates
augmented reality back to at
least 1901.  So, if you look at
this chart from Google trends,
in case you haven't used it
before, the Y  axis is the
search enjin  -- engine from 0
to 10 and the X is time.  So I
did a search for 200 years.  As
you can see, there's interesting
activity going on here.
Suddenly in the summer of 2016,
we see a huge peak, and people
are curious about the mysterious
AR thing.  This is when Pokemon
go was released.  People
wondered, whoa! What is augment
augmented reality, and what else
is possible with this thing?
This was probably the most
popular AR application, although
it's not fully AR capable, and
they're working on that fully AR
Pokemon go soon.  But this
opened the public's eyes into
the possibility of AR and showed
the potential for its scale.
Later, around the fall of
2017, we have another peak
that's starting to rise.  It's
not as high as Pokemon Go, this
was from AR core and ARKit that
were released around the same
time.  These are developer kits
that will allow people to build
experiences such as Pokemon Go
in a much easier and more
streamlined way.
So a quick definition, ARCore is
a platform for building AR apps
on Android, and ARKit is Apple's
version for building AR on iOs.
Looking back, this is as far
back as you can go.  There is
some activity going on.  People
are actually interested and
aware of augmented reality.
Especially around 2009.  So that
was almost ten years ago.  And
why does it seem like it's such
a new thing now? This is when AR
tool kit was released for web.
It's an open-sourced tool kit.
If you want to compare it to
ARCore and ARKit, and allowed
developers to build AR
applications.  The output would
be Flash-based.
This is one of the reasons it
didn't take on.  Users have to
install a plugin, and they have
to use their web cam in a weird
way that does not feel natural
compared to a mobile device,
where you can take it around
with you, and it makes more
sense to point at what you want
to project your AR object on to.
So, this really shows its
state.  This publication about
it describes what AR tool kit
is.  It shows AR tool kit in
action.  It's marker-based, so
they have this code where it
will project the object from the
code.  And then in the
documentation, you can also see
that it's using windows XP and
telling you how to use a web cam
on your computer.
Later in 2009, we have the
introduction of augmented
reality into the real world.
Esquire published this issue, it
was an augmented reality
special, and on the front cover,
you had this QR code you could
scan, and something magical
happens.  Robert Downey Jr.
Comes out of the screen and
starts acknowledging you.  As
you saw in the previous screen,
there were 12 pages of AR
content and lots of publications
were talking about it, and it
was becoming more noticeable to
consumers.
So fast forwarding to today,
we have back in 2012, Google
hangouts foments
filters, which was long before
snap
chat.  We have Pokemon Go, and
Ikea's furniture app from the
Apple store.
What's making this possible is
we have much more powerful
devices, much more powerful
browsers that will soon be
capable of AR.  Hopefully future
support on the web will help to
bring this technology to the
masses.
So let's go back to basics
and talk about what defines
augmented reality
apps.  So ARCore, again, is the
kit that allows developers to
use these defining features in
applications.  And these
defining features include motion
tracking, which allows the
device to understand and track
its position relative to the
real world.  So a scare crow
that you can place into the
world and move around and looks
stationary just like the people
next to it.  And environmental
understanding so the device can
detect the size and location.
Previously it was only
horizontal surfaces, but with
the new release, you can place
it on textured surfaces.  There
was a demo of placing things on
the snow, like around the tree.
And then light estimation, which
allows the device to estimate
the lighting conditions.  This
helps brings objects to life.
The Subtleties like shadows and
brightness can really make an
object in the real world look
real.
So, previously we had a
platform called tango, which
allowed augmented reality on
powerful devices, but we decided
we wanted to bring this to the
masses.  That's when we focused
our efforts from late last year
on ARCore, which will make
augmented reality possible on
more Android devices.  So that
is a huge challenge, but a
really big opportunity.  The
fact that there are 2 billion
plus active devices running on
Android.  And each of these has
their own unique hardware
requirements and specs that we
have to make sure align and
provide the same high quality
experience that we want all
users to have.
So currently, with the most
recent release, it works on 100
million devices including 13
unique models.  And we're
working with partners to make
sure that more devices can
support this.
Going back to ARKits.  This
is the software developer kit
allowing developers to use the
same essential features in iOS
11.  It's very similar to the
three basic AR features that
ARCore suggests.  Those are
essential AR features, not like
AR core.  They can be described
for any augmented reality app.
And the device compatibility,
most recent Apple devices.
So with iPhone 6S and above, and
some of the newer iPads.
Let's talk about building for
web.  All of this allows you to
build native apps, and this is a
JS conference, so you are
probably bored thinking about
building an app.  We want to
build for web.  So let's see
what's possible.  ARCore has an
experiment exploring the
possibilities of web support,
and it will lower the barrier to
enter, which people can build
apps and release them out to the
web.  This is a pre-standards
experimentation, just trying to
see what's possible.  It's
basically a wrapper of chromium
extending web VR features, so
it's really
scalable.  So they have this
cool demo called article, which
you can download on get  GitHub
and run it on the server.  It's
super easy.
ARCore is not one single
entity.  You're building a web
app with AR capabilities.
You're running it on the
experimental browser that is
supposed to emulate what the web
standards might look like.
Currently they have experimental
browsers that work on Android
and iOS.
And most of the examples on
the web AR for ARCore demos are
built with 3JS.  It's a popular
library used since 2010.  Some
of Google's projects have
used it, and all of these other
cool Google and non-gilt
experiments you see here.  It
allows you to create 3D shapes,
animations, complex scenes, and
gives you tools to make this
easier.  3D modeling concepts
are really hard.
So this is one of the tools that
it provides.  It's an in-browser
shape editor or scene editor.
It allows you to control all the
different parameters.  And it's
a really good way to start
learning 3D modeling, especially
if you haven't been paying
attention in math class.  You
have to relearn mapping and
matrix multiplication, and
sometimes it's
overwhelming.  With time, you
can make 3D creations like this.
If you are having trouble, you
can download some models on poly
and find these different kinds
of cheese burgers.  Search for
the term, and you will find
items tagged with that
description.  And if you really
like these cheeseburgers, you
can put them together, start
throwing them in the air, and
that's your AR app.
So just to highlight what's
possible with 3JS, this is one
of the apps that my team has
built, and it helps people
find the direction prayer for.
This is basically just usek web
RTC to use the camera and
navigation APIs.  And basically
it's projecting this into space
rather than as we have learned
as an essential AR feature.  It
doesn't allow you to place it on
to a detected surface.  It's a
kind of faux AR, but it's -- I
guess you can compare it to
Pokemon Go, where you're not
really throwing the Pokeball on
to the Pokemon.  It's not on the
floor.  Sometimes it's floating
around.  So that's kind of one
distinction of what's possible
with 3JS and how we need to
bridge the gap.  There is a
library called 3.AR.JS, which
detects the device compatibility
and interfaces with a web VR
extension that is exposed by the
experimental browsers.  That's
what is allowing you to throw
things on to surfaces and detect
it with precision.
So putting it all together,
you can create useful apps.  For
example, this living room
modeling.  There's useful things
you can do for consumers,
especially if it's available for
the web.  People can reach these
experiences from a link, and
access them if their device is
compatible.
So, again, the web AR and AR
core implementation is an
experiment to explore what is
possible and what might be
potential web standards.  There
are more possibilities.  Moz://a
has their possibility, and there
are a lot of commonalties in the
pre-standards proposals right
now.  Things are starting to
align, and hopefully we have
standards, too.  I think one of
the most popular ones might be
the marker-based ar.js.  If you
recognize the markers from my
earlier slides, it's because
it's based on AR tool kit.  So
it goes way back.  With all of
these standards that are not
fully in place, why should we
care now? What if it changes and
it stresses you out to learn all
of these new things? With 3D
modeling, it's a big concept to
grasp, and if you start learning
it now, there's a lot to catch
up on.  People have been 3D
modeling for decades.  If you're
interested, start equipping
yourself with the basic
knowledge to get started.  And
people are already building
really cool stuff right now.
Some sources of inspiration,
there are ARCore-specific
examples.  There's an ARKit
version at the bottom there.
One of my favorites is here,
which just features some of
Google's -- I am not biased or
anything -- some of Google's AR
experiments.  But one of the
reasons I love it so much is
half of the experiments were
created by women.  So that's
awesome to show that
representation in the web XR
community.  And going back to
Ivan Sutherland, the professor
who created the first
head-mounted
display.  With all of these
advancements, I think we're
getting close to that.
Although we might not be close
to the really complex
head-mounted displays, I think
it's exciting that we are
getting really close to building
web-based AR applications.
That's what is really going to
make AR become more widespread.
So thank you guys for
listening.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you so much, Raisa.
I have a question for you on
AR.
I want to get your viewpoint on
what you're most excited about
on the types of experiences that
users will get from web AR?
>> RAISA CUEVAS: Yeah, I
mean, I'm really excited about
web AR, because it's going to
open it up to more users.  There
won't be the barrier of entry to
have a specific device.  It has
to be one of the compatible
devices.  But they won't have to
download a specific app, and it
opens up the possibilities.  But
some of the use cases that I'm
excited about is education.  We
currently have the Google
expeditions, which was formerly
like a VR classroom experiment,
but they have expanded it to AR,
so kids can use their phones in
class and see volcanos erupting
on the floor or see the planets
in the sky.  It's a good way to
see that interactively.
>> I wish I could go
back-to-school.
>> RAISA CUEVAS: Definitely.
>> Thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
Our next talk is another
creative talk.  It was previewed
earlier in the intros.  It's the
paint splatter technology that's
being used right now, outside.
So it's by -- I don't know if
I'm going to say this right.
Halldór -- Halldór and pórour
Hans Baldursson.  I think that's
Halldór -- Halldór
to talk to us about the colorful
painter technology that's all
over the concert hall them.
They're right now.
Vandalism without consequences.
And how they turned Harpa into a
giant LED-lit facade, into a
collaborative art work that can
be used by everyone.  They make
up the two-man digital arts
studio that is Staffly.
Is that right? Together they
created a few interactive art
installations.  They most
notable work is the one that's
outside utilizing the LED
facade.
While they set up, help me
welcome them to the stage.  Hall
Hall --
Halldór and pórour Hans
Baldursson [ Applause ]
>> HALLDￓR: Hello. My name
is Halldór.
>> HANS: Hello.
>> HALLDￓR: I'm going to
begin by telling you a little
bit about myself.  I have a
bachelor's degree in computer
science, a BS in CS, or a bull
shit degree in counter.  I also
do my fair share of websites and
whatnotes.  My second job is as
a musician.  I compose music,
and I also am in a band, which
you should totally check out, if
you haven't already.  And I
collaborate with musicians on a
new robotic piano project.  Some
of my work is
most notably a generated music
piece, and it's writteden in
JavaScript.  It uses the photos
taken during the moon landings
back in the '60s and '70s as an
input to a musical engine, and
creates sound scoopss --
soundscapes.
There is ambient music generated
in the browser.  And another
project is the infinite string
quartet, which is a modular
string quartet, written by my
brother, who is also a composer.
And we created an interactive
version of it that runs in the
browser.  And you can select
modules or clips from the string
quartet, and make a 3D space
around you.  You can play for
hours, creating creepy string
quartet music with this.
And then the project I'm
working on here.  Here we are
contemplating how to make it
sound more like a flower.  You
know, artists.  That is being
released very soon.
>> HANS: I work for the local
contracting company.  I'm also
going to use the opportunity to
talk about some of my projects,
since I have this
platform.
This is a Chrome extension.
Woo!
It takes all of the works and
replaces them.  Here we have
bacon.  And that gets replaced
with this.  Recently, just
earlier this month, we did
another project using the facade
outside.  This was
done, and basically a giant
heart projected.  The input is
users' heart rate.
>> HALLDￓR: So let's talk
about paint splatter.  It's an
interactive installation where
you can participate on your
phone.  And the simplest way to
describe it is that
it's a giant digital canvas made
out of the huge LED facade.  And
anyone with access to internet
or a smart device or a computer
can interact with the cameras by
splashing virtual paint on it,
which drips straight down or
sideways depending on wind
direction and force.  Take it
away.
>> HANS: So, when you're
creating collective art, it's
important that the user input is
simple and rewarding.  Most
people like vandalizing,
especially without consequences.
So anonymously splashing paint
on Iceland's most expensive
painting seemed like a rewarding
and simple way to be an outlet
for that kind of behavior.
For the first few days we
had thousands of visits from
people all over the world.  And
some people standing outside in
the storm splashing for hours.
The reason why it became so
popular is our interactiveness.
The fact that by touching a
small area on your phone
resulted in a giant blob visible
to all participants all over the
world.  It's also visibly
pleasing.  The blobs have
different looks.  We could avoid
making this look like a giant,
shared Microsoft paint document.
We could avoid
mankind's most drawn art work
ever, the phallic symbol.
>> HALLDￓR: The design process
was straightforward.  It started
with conceptual sketches on
paper, like all good ideas
start.  And the whole concept
was thoroughly determined before
we started coding anything.  So
that helped us really keep
things in scope.  And we did
one thing well.
The next step was doing some
web mock-ups just to get a gist
of how the animation would look
like.  And I'm going to show you
a code pen I did here.
>> HANS: This is not the code
pen.
>> HALLDￓR: No, this is my home.
This is where I live.  I used to
keep this
on my screen.
Here it is.  Here
is the first directive, and how
with input parameters, how it
would leak to get a sense of the
rendering and main obstacles.
This took like 30 minutes to do.
And it was so good to have this
with the project proposal.
Okay.  Back to the
presentation.  The biggest
unknown factor in the whole
project was how to render stuff
from the
light facade, but it had been
done before.  So we got access
to node.js server access code
written
by Owen Hendley.
The networking part was also
pretty straightforward.  We used
socket.io, and you press and
make a blob, and it sends the
event to all connected
participants.  And it also
contains some rudimentary game
logic and input sanitizing and
UX
throttling.
So when we set that up, we
faced some real-world problems.
The server had to be located in
the basement with the rest of
the controllers, that meant we
had to go up and down and up and
down endlessly in our feedback
loop.  This is a video of one of
those times.  But it was great
physical exercise.
>> And we also got lost a few
times.  It was like Hogwart's
school.
>> I think there are a lot of
people stuck down there.
>> Probably is a small
population there by now.
>> Yeah. And this was online,
we wanted to allow more people
to participate.  So we decided
to set up our live stream.  With
our limited budget, we picked up
the phone and duct taped it to
the ceiling of the hotel lobby
across from the
location.  But soon, people
started complaining about the
tourist bus blocking the view.
And also the staff at the
hotel, they were not pleased
about the unidentified phone
that was possibly broadcasting
their conversations to the
internet.
>> Yeah. We also encountered
some problems with deploying the
rendered server at Harpa.  We
had to connect our computer
through six unmarked ether net
cables, and had to be done in
correct order for it to work.
It was most definitely not a
very atomic deployment process.
Almost like programming punch
card
programs.
>> So we had to become like a
small tourist station.
>> Yeah.
>> We had to fulfill our duties
as a live TV station.
Did you already mention the main
complaint from the
Reddit users?
The tour bus?
>> Yeah, yeah. You're not even
listening to me.
>> And then we got spammed.
It was bound
to happen.
Somebody found a way to
circumvent our rate limiting.
Oh no! And why am I telling you
programmers and JavaScript
people? And then we got, like,
properly hacked.
Now this is actually a very
funny story, because somebody
found a way to override our
color scheme.  We had like a
very limited color scheme.  You
could not draw black, for
instance.  So you could not
clear the screen or something
like that.  But somebody found a
way to override it, and were
suddenly able to draw arbitrary
buffers of images.  We knew this
was a possibility from the
start, but didn't have the
resources to prevent it, except
for some basic rate limiting and
exponentially increasing buffer
periods.
But this was a very fun
challenge, and war was upon us.
Iceland is very small, and the
communities here are even
smaller.  The proof for that is
that I just got on messenger and
guessed who the hacker was.
And this was  before the hacker
started writing his name on the
facade.  He was my former
computer game programming
teacher at university, and he's
also a programmer at CCP.  And
the only person in Iceland I
knew that would be able to do
such a thing, and invest the
time to do it properly.
[ Laughter ]
So I could immediately
recognize his way of doing the
hacking, because it was very
professionally done.  We
approached him and after
negotiations, he surrendered and
told us all about how he did it.
He sent his code and a lot of
comments on our code, which was
very fun to read.  So he was
able to draw arbitrary buffers
with paint.  This is where he
was like neatly organizing his
name in a two-dimensional
array.
He wrote a whole rendering
service that was running on his
computer that spun to our server
with paint blob events that
enabled him to do this.  So he
was rendering on a rendering
server, because we all like
rendering servers, right?
But, we made it harder for
him.  We just increased the rate
limiting of it, and added some
extra throttling without
degrading the experience of the
normal, non-spamming user.  And
this fight was ongoing
throughout the duration of the
display.  He also was able to
avoid, because the
paint leaks.
If you draw something, it won't
stay there forever, because it
gets -- the paint leaks.
Somebody else paints over it.
He added the skewing factor he
could tune to his tastes to be
able to create very straight
images.  Then we added random
noise to it to decrease the
resolution of what this hacker
was able to draw.  And this is
still in the code.  You see it
if you press the -- if you splat
paint, you can see that it --
>> A receptor.
>> It doesn't come exactly in
the center of where you
clicked.
And it's totally on concept,
because splatting paint with
some paint blob is an unprecise
art.  It's just part of the
concept.
>> If you spend some time in
Iceland, you quickly learn that
the weather here is quite
unpredictable.  When we did this
the first time in 2016, there
was basically a crazy storm
throughout the whole time it was
up.  And that was a great way to
show off the feature that we
were using wind force and wind
direction to render.  So we just
looked on the bright side.
There were a
-- were not a lot of people
outside trying it out, mostly
inside.  The next time, the
weather was way better.
Nice weather and almost no wind
at all.  We were somewhere in
our calculations, we were
dividing by zero.  For the first
time this happened, we were
going to be on live television,
and this happened like five
minutes before that happened.
And as you can see in this
picture, here's the mayor.
Loads of wind.  You can see his
hair.  It's crazy.  In 2017,
this is a frozen server with no
wind and we are somewhere in the
back having a panic attack.  We
somehow got through the
interview demonstrating how it
worked without it actually
working at all.  Nobody seemed
to notice, which was a pretty
good thing.
>> We learned a few lessons
through the whole process.
First being that we
should avoid any ribbon cutting
ceremonies, especially when it's
on live television.  Secondly,
you should always allow for the
weather, even when you're
writing code, even if it has
nothing to do with weather.  You
should do it, especially here in
Iceland.
>> And it's always fun when
your work is worth hacking.  At
least when it's not done
maliciously, and it's
entertaining.  This piece
revolves around the concept of
vandalism, and that everybody
gets their say.  Everybody can
participate.  So programmers
with the programming skills,
they can, of course,
participate, but if you intend
to do so, please behave
yourselves.  We don't have the
money to
fight you.  Thank you so much
for listening.  And the piece is
accessible at
point.jsconf.is.  Or just
paint.is.  It's been a pleasure
talking here.  We would like to
know if any of you had any
questions? We are happy
to answer.
You have a question there? [
Inaudible Question ].
Yeah?  to answer.
You have a question there? [
The insights of how many
users and how many users at the
same time have used this? The
night when it went live on
reddit, we got like 7,000 hits
in a certain period of time.
And that was after we set up the
live streaming cam.  So even if
you were abroad, you could splat
paint and see a live stream of
it actually
happening.  That was not -- it
was a pretty even spike >>
And the log file from the server
was around 300mb, if that tells
you anything.  Anymore
questions?
>> Oh yeah. Uh-huh.
[ Inaudible Question ].
>> Yeah. We did one, a
couple of weeks ago, which we
told you about briefly.  It's --
we connected a heart rate sensor
to heart animation on the front
of Harpa, so you could go
connect to the sensor that could
connect to your heart rate, and
it blended nicely on the light
facade.
>> And we allowed for zero, but
no one had zero heart
rate.
[ Laughter ]
[ Inaudible Question ]
>> Sorry?
>> It was taken down because the
hotel manager thought we were
spying on some guests in the
hotel.  And our friend needed
his phone back as well.
[ Laughter ]
>> Poor guy.
>> We'll take care of it.
>> Just ask away, if you have
any questions.
>> What is the time-out? Two
seconds? Four seconds? Eight
seconds? A silly TCP joke.
Sorry.  Thank you so much for
listening.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you. I think their
talk is a perfect segue into our
next talk.  The next talk talks
about security and how to, you
know, protect your web apps.  So
our next talk will be Dominik.
If you will come on stage so we
can set up.  Dominik is a
developer evangelist in Berlin.
He's passionate about
JavaScript, hack-a-thons,
teaching, and also good whiskey.
You'll usually find him speaking
at conferences like this or
meet-ups or mentoring in
hack-a-thons.  He's going to be
talking to us about about XSS,
CSRF, CSP, JWT.  The title of
the talk says what the fuck.  I
don't know.  So if he can come
up on stage to
set up.  There he is.  I think I
see him.
set
>> I'm going to spit out some
random Icelandic trivia that
I've learned from looking up
random Icelandic facts.  I've
never been to Iceland, and this
is my first time, you know,
here,
obviously.  One of them is
apparently there's an Icelandic
naming committee that decides
whether your child's name or
even your name is a valid name.
So I don't think my name is
valid at all in Iceland.  So I
think I'm an illyy
-- illegal named person here.
No one tell the Icelandic naming
commission
that.
So update.  Apparently we're
running pretty early.  So we can
get a 12-minute break and just
come back here in 12 minutes so
we can continue
on time.
Live Captions by:
@smiley845 with @whitecoatcapxg.
>> Okay. I think we're finally
ready for the next talk.
The live stream must be really
confused.
Dominik is a programming
evangelist.  You will find him
normally speaking at conferences
like this, meet-ups, or
mentoring in hack-a-thons.  He
will be talking to us about all
of these abbreviations up here,
and how to protect yourself and
your users from the new
generation of bobby tables.  So
give it up for Dominik.
[ Applause ]
>> Welcome everyone. Is this
mic on? Can you hear me? Thumbs
up? Awesome.  I think I have the
most click-baity title.  I will
not read all of the
abbreviations, because that
wastes half of the time.  I
would like to give you a quick
introduction to web security.
And this is not going to be
making you all web security
experts.  But one thing I that
want to make sure is all of the
topics that I highlight are
topics that I think every web
developer should be aware of
when they build an application.
Before we start, I would
like to quickly introduce
myself.  I'm a developer
evangelist for a company called
twilio.  We do APIs to send and
receive text messages and other
things around communications.  I
live in Berlin.  But there's one
more thing you should know about
me.  I can drop this jacket now,
because it's getting really
warm.  And this is where the
talk gets awkward.  All right.
So I'm a member of
a group called woed
onsie.js.  I think there is a
unicorn running around.  But,
you know, like, today, we have
so many social networks and
communication channels, but
there isn't really one for
onsie-loving developers.  So
being a developer myself, I did
what every developer does when
something doesn't exist.  So I
built the future great social
network called onesie life.  I'm
not sure why I don't have high
traffic yet, but it will come.
And like being a developer,
I made sure this is as secure
as possible.  And doesn't have
any vulnerabilities, especially
nothing that can be hacked with
a banana.  You know I thought of
everything.  It uses HTTPS, and
I don't have to pay a dime for
that.  It uses HSPS, which just
makes sure there's no
downgrading of the traffic.
This is typically what blocks
you from going to Google.com
when there's a public Wi-Fi with
a captive
model.  I don't allow mixed
content.  So no HTTP content on
a website that is certified
HTTPS.  I sanitize the HTML.  So
I allow people to put a mark
down, but I will make sure to
send it before it goes to the
page.  And there is no room for
SQL injections, because I'm not
using a real database.
So there's no way to have the
injections.  And I'm not talking
about NoSQL databases, but I'm
literally using a plain start,
because I don't believe this
will scale.  But turns out that
developing secure web
applications isn't as secure as
I thought.  So I contacted my
buddy, Bob Allison.  And he took
a stab at the application and
figured out a bunch of security
vulnerabilities that I would
like to share with you.  Now
it's really warm.  So I will
take this off.
All right.  So, if we go
to this page.  I will set an
HTTP cookie to maintain the
session.
It's just a way that allows you
to to maintain session state
throughout multiple sessions by
setting a value either by HTTP
headers or via JavaScript.  If
we go into the console here, we
can access that.  I have one
that is called off token.  This
is what is called a JWT or JSON
web token.  We can see that it
has three different parts, a
header, a red part, a purple
part which is like the payload,
and then it has a signature.
That's generated by an algorithm
that is specified in the header
using a secret.  If we look
here, it says invalid signature,
because I was smart enough not
to use "secret" as my secret,
but there is a vulnerability in
my app around this that
we can exploit.  There are
different algorithms that you
can use, and one of them that is
mandatory in the spec is none.
Disregard the
signature.  If we do this, and
let's have fun.  We switched the
role to Admin.  And then I copy
this part.  And this is just
basic code.  This is just plain
data.  Don't think this is
secure or something.  And I will
set this as an off
token.  We can refresh the page,
and we will see that we are now
in Admin mode.  And that is
because I'm
taking the JWT as a single
source of truth.  If I say I'm
an Admin, I am.  That in
combination with the algorithm
that is none, we can kind of
just switch anything.  And I
wouldn't have had to log in in
the first place.  I could have
generated this with any user
name and sign in as anyone.  How
can we protect ourselves from
that? You can set cookies via
JavaScript or HTTP headers.  And
you can declare cookies as HTTP
only.  They will still be sent
by the browser, but you will not
be able to access and manipulate
them.  And an assigned cookie
means I could not manipulate
without knowing the token and
that it's secured.  But there's
another thing I should have
done, and that
revolves around jaws.  I'm using
the library on node, but I'm
using an old version, and that
one has two flaws that the newer
one fixes.
On the one hand, the library
should provide you with a way to
white list algorithms.  In this
case, I'm in the secure version
of this, I'm saying that I only
allow HS256 tokens versus
nothing else.  And then the
other thing is in this library,
for example, if the secret is
set to something that is not
null, the library will not
accept none as an algorithm.
But that's only in the newer
libraries.  So the bottom line
here is stay up to date.  You
don't want to be the next
Equifax.  There was an older
version of an implementation
that was known to be vulnerable
and them not getting around to
updating it.  You don't want to
be in the news far that.
This is a social network, so
we can post stuff.  Let me jump
back here and post something.
This is marked, so I can write
something like hi, JSConf
Iceland.  And I will post this
and look at the traffic.  We
will see that -- if I make this
bigger, there's an HTTP post why
here that sets the token along
and sends the form data in the
bottom.  This is nice, because
it's really easy to implement.
I'm literally submitting a form
asynchronously.  But the
combination of form and cookies
is also something that can cause
a request forgery attack by
hackers.  To give you an idea of
how this works and what this is,
this is -- sometimes it's
written as XXRF or CSRF, but
typically pronounced "c-surf."
If you get back to the page and
refresh here, you see that the
attacker was able to post on my
behalf on the page.  The reason
why this works is the browser is
super eager to send all of these
cookies along on every request.
If we look at the code that
hacked us here, it, on body
unload, it will submit the form
that we have here.  In this case
it is visible, but it could have
been hidden.  There is an input
tag with a message we want to
send.  It could be hidden.  It
doesn't have to be visible.  And
then hit submit.  This is the
danger about this, because the
browser is super eager to send
this.  So let's talk about how
we can
fix this.  Let me find my slides
again.  Apparently it was hacked
twice by this application.
Let's navigate and talk about
what happened here.
When I clicked on the link here,
I'm using a target blank here.
The attacker's page can access
my page window by using
window.opener.application, and
rewrite that application.  In
that case, the attacker page was
navigating me to another
harmless page, but this could
have just as well been a
redirection to a phishing page
that looks like your page.
Someone could put in a page
filling that redirects the
original browser to a phishing
page.  Luckily, protecting
yourself from that is pretty
straightforward.  You want to
use the rel attribute and set it
to no opener and no defer.  You
don't want to provide access to
window.opener, and there is no
refer because some browsers
don't support no opener.  Namely
IE and older versions of Edge.
You want to use the no refer as
well.  Plus there are some
JavaScript scripts that allow
you to circumvent this as well.
To get back to the CSRF
attacks, the approach is
relatively straight-forward as
well.  The basic idea is that
you will generate a new cookie
called
_CSRF.  You pass it as a cookie
and embed it into the page that
is supposed to have form
submission and a hidden input
field.  When you submit the post
request, in this case, you will
check if the value in the cookie
equals the same value that is
either passed in the request
body and the request query
parameters or in one of
the headers like the ones in the
example which are the wins that
the CSRF library checks for.  In
that case, that works.  If it's
not the case, it's likely
someone will perform a CSRF
attack against you.  They are
not able to read the cookie
since the browser auto-submits
this, so they will not be able
to pass this as a header.
Let's talk about Sammy.  The
reason is, to first give you
background about little bobby
tables, if you're not familiar
with that, it comes from this
comic, which is a joke about
squill injections who named
their family like a squill
injections, and the principle
being Mac, because they lost the
student records because they
were not sanitizing the input.
Does anyone know what this
source code is from? I would be
really impressed if someone
knows this by heart.  This is
the myspace or Sammy worm.  Some
of you might be familiar with
this.  This was an attack from
2005 on Myspace, which would
repost this code, add Sammy as
your friend and post that Sammy
is awesome.  That's also how
they caught him.  If the access
code points at your Myspace
profile, that's not smart idea.
The cool thing about this attack
is it shows a couple of things
that people used to circumvent
the protection.  One thing they
said is they don't allow script
tags, didn't allow JavaScript
call-in in URLs and stuff, but
they did allow in-line
CSS.  And because he wasn't
allowed to use quotes, he took
all of his code, wrapped it into
an evaland put it into another
HTML attribute, and that would
be
evaluated.
They have lists of words,
like this.
But, what Sammy just did, he
turned this into strings, split
them by a plus, and recon
catinated them.  And then
there's the other thing.  You
say I could block eval, and
that's fine.  Those are all ways
to evaluate code.  The last one
is from a project that I'm not
sure if I can name the name,
because I'm not sure if it
violates a code of conduct, but
talk to Martin, and he can tell
you the name.  Or I can tell you
the name afterwards.  But the
bottom line is there are a bunch
of ways to write the same code
in JavaScript.  You can't
blacklist certain words, because
that doesn't help you.
So blocking XSS is not
trivial.  And I have a demo for
that as well.  I told you I'm
use mark down here, and a
library called marked.  If
you're a few versions back, but
not really old, even though it
has a function that allows you
to sanitize stuff.  So we can do
stuff like alert 1, and this
will not work.  There is a
security vulnerability in here.
We can create links, right? I
can do something like "click
me." And in here, if we would
write JavaScript:alert hello
JSConf.  This doesn't work
directly because the sanitizer
is smarter than that.  Shout out
to Guy from Sneak who actually
showed this to me.  Let's do
some fun stuff with
encoding.
This here is literally the same
as a closing parentheses.  And a
colon is
the same as this.  We don't have
the closing pieces anymore, but
we're getting there.  Now we can
use a quirkiness in the browser,
and actually write this here.
And what this will do, let's
first try this.  It works.  And
the reason why this works is
that the browser -- so first of
all, the HTML sanitizer will see
this, and it doesn't see
JavaScript:
JavaScript: But I think you
meant a semi colon, so I'll be a
good guy and insert this.  So
this is valid, and it doesn't
complain about that, and we can
do anything afterwards.  We've
seen this work.  The bottom line
here is encoding can be
dangerous.  Don't trust any code
that your user
can modify.
Don't trust CSS.  And Greg just
tweeted about this two days ago.
Really don't trust it.  There's
a bunch of stuff you can do, and
I highly recommend you check out
the blog post in this tweet.
Let's talk about another
thing, and that's JSON with
padding.  It's being used less
these days.  But basically it's
a way to circumvent samor
general policy.  The way it
works is you define a global
function.  If you just Jquery's
JSON p method, but it's a call
function that has to be global,
and you expect the data to be
passed into the code.  And you
inject a script tag with the J
son P URL.  You define the name
of the function in this case,
it's called got post.  It will
take the name and wrap the data
into a function called with that
name.  If you use that, but you
write poor JSONP, now this is
getting fun.  My JSONP end point
does not verify what I pass as a
call-back, and that means that
we can -- I'm in the wrong
place.  We can generate
arbitrary JavaScript here, and
this gets really fun.  I'm going
to first show it to you and then
explain what's going on.  This
is a bit of a longer code
snippet, so I will copy this.
So I'm going to press this and
click this button.  And nothing
happens.  But if I refresh the
page, we get this.  And I can
refresh as many times as I want.
It will stay like this.  The
reason why this is happening, if
we go to application, I
installed a service worker.  If
you don't know what service
workers are, they're an API from
the browser that allows you to
handle the network proxies so
that you can -- it's made for
things like offline available
apps so you can cache your web
website and your resources and
handle which ones you want to
cache and which ones you don't.
It can do pretty much anything
because it can intercept the
network requests.  The browsers
are smart enough to be sure a
service worker can only be
installed from your domain.  But
if your domain has a vulnerable
JSONP interaction, then you have
a problem like this.  We can see
the call-back parameter here is
really long.  We can see what's
actually happening.  I'm
creating a service worker
script.  And the data, I don't
care about.  I just commented.
We just reply with a hack and a
script tag injected.  This is an
obvious attack, but you could do
it in a less obvious way as
well.  You could actually fetch
the page, inject the script tag,
and send that to the user, and
the user will not recognize
this.  Especially not a common
user with the dev tools to check
the service worker
install? Open that, and you will
see how many people actually
install service workers.  You
have no idea what these service
workers do.  It's sort of a
dangerous attack.
Let's actually remove this or I
will forget about it.
Unregister.  If we reload this
now, and you don't want to
explain your customers, go to
your browser and click on
application in the dev tools and
click on unregister on this
thing called service worker.
So far we've seen different
attacks, and we should fix all
of these and also all the other
attacks that we have in there.
There is a new super hero in
town that allows you to protect
yourself against some of these,
and that's called content
security Policy, or CSP.  All
that I'm doing is injecting an
HTTP header.  We can see if I
click on any of these, and
refresh, nothing
happens.  23  -- if we open
this, we will see a bunch of
errors.  What does that actually
mean? Content security policy is
just an HTTP header that you can
define rules that the browser
should play by for your
resources.  These can be things
like by default.  For scripts
and styles, I only want the
things that have the following
non-s.  This can't be hard coded
by the attacker.
That means no more in line
scripts unless they have this
HTML attribute, no in line
styles.  And that's why the
attacks don't work.  And
blocking objects here, image
source, I'm only specifying
self, and the user.  I only
allow Google fonts.  I block all
mixed content, so no HTTP
content on my page.  And I
specify a report URI, and it
will be pinged with every
violation.  There are tools you
can point this against.  You can
point this against any end point
on your server, and this will
report it.  There's a
report-only flag, and that
allows you to say that you want
to only get the information that
something has been violated, but
you don't block the actual
content.  This is great for
transitioning into it,
especially if you want to test
this first in a local
environment or something.  CSP
should not be your security
strategy, it should be your
safety net.  Writing of really
strong CSP is hard, and there's
a great paper by Google about
this, like about the dangers
about this.  You should still
care about the attacks.
A couple of other things
that you should look out for.
You should disallow framing.
Most websites don't have a
legitimate reason to be allowing
to be iframed, what an attacker
can do is place your page with
an opacity of zero above their
page and line up buttons so that
they -- user thinks they're
interacting with their page, but
they're really interacting with
your page.  And so this is what
people could use, for example,
to, like, if you want to like a
page.
Facebook blocks iframing.
Don't show versions of front-end
libraries and servers.  There
are packages that are useful to
develop things, but if you show
a version number in your HTML
page or HTTP headers, this gives
an attacker the right idea of
what security vulnerabilities to
test out.  And you don't want to
make their job
easier.  And check for types of
input because there can be NoSQL
injections.
Don't just assume that it's a
string.  There are some partial
libraries that will parse things
like objects as well.  If you do
that, the result is that you
could, for example, have a NoSQL
injection.
Other things? Consider security
audits, especially if your code
base has never had a security
audit.  If you don't have an
internal security expert,
contract one.  Because there's
so many things that it's really
hard to keep up with that this
is really helpful.  And you
learn yourself a lot if you look
over their shoulder.  That's how
I learned most of the stuff is
when I had to go through a
security audit with a feature.
And then stay up to date
with versions.  You don't want
to be the next Equifax.
Similarly, use a tool to detect
security vulnerabilities in your
dependencies.  You can write the
most secure code, but if your
dependencies are vulnerable,
that defeats the
purpose.  So, sneak is one of
them.  They provide patches if
they are too late.  So marked
fixed that
volley ne'er--
vulnerability.  But Snyk has a
patch.  And there are other
tools that check for this as
well.  GitHub scans and tells
you about vulnerabilities as
well.
So to wrap this up, use
signed only HTTP cookies.  Be
skeptical of JWPs.  Use no
opener and no refer on your
target lines.  You CSRF tokens.
It's easy to use.  Blocking SSX
is not trivial.  If you have
user input or query parameters,
think of these and know that
they can cause harm.  Be aware
of encoding, because there are a
million ways to write the same
thing.  Be careful of JSONP.  It
should only accept call
characters.  Use CSP as a safety
net, and most importantly, stay
up to date.  I put up the slides
here, and I will tweet the link
in a second, so you can check
them out again.  Similarly, the
source code of the website is on
this URL, including different
files for every one of these
vulnerabilities that I showed
you and a couple others in
there, including resources that
are interesting about their
respective topic.  With that, I
thank you for your attention.  I
will be around for the rest of
the day wearing likely this
jacket instead of the onesie.
Come by, ask me questions, and
thank you for your attention.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you so much. I have a
question for you.  So, what do
you think we as software
engineers can do to advocate in
our own companies to actually do
more things for security?
>> I think sort of highlighting
past examples.
There is a
great talk by @jawegg on
Twitter.  He has a great talk
online talking about different
instances where people were
hacked because of security
vulnerabilities.  Showing these
things.  You don't want to be in
this situation, right? Security
is a preemptive strategy.  You
should always have security in
mind, because if you have to
think about security because of
an attack, it's too late.  So
you always should think of this
ahead of time.
>> Thank you so much. Again,
Dominik.  So we have a break for
30 minutes.  So go get your
coffee.  I think I need coffee.
Any body thinks I'm in New York,
still.  Head out, and come back
in 30 minutes.
[ Break
]
Live Captions by:
@smiley845 with @whitecoatcapxg
>> Hello. Okay. Hello,
everyone.  Welcome to our
lightning talk part of the
event.  So, it's going to be
seven lightning talks, and we're
going to be starting
with Andy.
I have a timer on my iPad timing
them.  We're a little strict
about it.  Here's Andy talking
to us about TypeScript.
Awesome.
[ Applause ]
>> Hi. I'm Andy. And I work at
shopify.  Today I'm going to be
giving you a whirlwind
introduction to TypeScript.  A
brief disclaimer, most of the
stuff I'm going to talk about
today is TypeScript-specific,
but TypeScript is not the only
way to bring types into your
JavaScript.  There are other
options.  I first started with
flow, and we switched to
TypeScript at work, so that's
what I do most of the time.  But
they're all great.
Okay.  So first, I want to
give you a little bit of why to
use types.  This is probably the
most important, and then we'll
dive into TypeScript syntax to
hopefully make it less scary to
get started.  I really want to
talk about two main reasons that
you would want to use types in
your project.  The first one is
if you're working on a large
application, as that application
grows, it's impossible to keep
in your own mind everything
that's happening.  If you're
working on a small library, like
maybe the overhead of types is
overkill.  Be  but if you're
working on a large application,
it will get to the point that
you can't keep track of all of
the changes that are happening
to functions or other interfaces
in your application, but the
compiler can keep track of that.
It's like having a super-powered
buddy on your team who will keep
track of everything that's
happening.
The second thing is that it's
really hard to keep
documentation up to date,
whether it be comments in your
code, or whether it be a read me
or whatever else.  The nice
thing about types is they make
your code a little more
self-documenting.  Since the
compiler is going to be
enforcing those types, it's a
lot harder to get them out of
date.  It's definitely possible
and easy to do things that still
make it hard to understand, but
it's a little bit of a help to
make your code easier to jump
into.
All right.  So, basic types.
We're going to start going
pretty fast through syntax here
to give an overview.  So here is
like sort of a hello_world of
primitive types in TypeScript.
It looks like normal JavaScript,
but you have a colon and the
name of a type, which is how
you're going to annotate your
variables.  That actually isn't
necessary a lot of the time.  I
more often than not don't have
to add explicit annotations to
my code, because TypeScript is
very good at inferring what I
mean.
You can also see here, this
is where the benefit starts
coming in.  This screen shot is
from visual studio code, but
it's a reflex of the error that
the compiler is putting out.
You can see it has a red
squiggly, because the it doesn't
have the call.
Arrays.  You have an annotation.
You put square brackets after it
to say that it's an array.  I
have this array of foods, and if
I initialize it to these
strings, it's happy.  If I push
in a new string, it's still
happy.  But if I were to try to
initialize it, or push in a
bollion, it would complain and I
would have to fix that.  So your
functions, you will be inporting
them all over your application.
Those were contrived examples,
because you can look at your
variables three or four lines
above.  But a function, this is
where you're going to be able to
catch things across your
application as you import
things.  You can see here that I
typed my parameter with that
same annotation.  There's
another annotation after the
arguments list, which is the
return type.  And then we just
write normal JavaScript on the
inside.  If I pass race car, it
will be happy, but bullion, it
will complain.  It is smart at
figuring out what return types
are, so you can omit the return
type if you don't want to do so
much typing.
All right.
Unions.  This is something that
I use all the time.  It's like
an or.  I want to say that a
vegetable can be a broccoli or a
carrot.  Fruit can be any of
these fruits.  And I use unions
with types.  I can say an
ingredient for this restaurant
is going to be a vegetable or a
truth,
fruit.
If I try to make this sludge
drink out of bread and bacon, it
will not be happy because it's
neither a vegetable or a fruit.
Interfaces.  This is how you
type objects.  This looks a lot
like plain object notation.  You
have a colon, and instead of the
value, you put your type name.
You also can use all of these
other features inside of your
interfaces.  So here we have a
union between a bunch of
animals.  You can have your
favorite.  You can make it
optional by allowing nulls, and
TypeScript will help you check
null before you access the
values or anything like that.
All right.  So most of my
day I spend writing React, and
that is where TypeScript really
shines for me.  I like it when
I'm writing plain TypeScript,
but for React components, I
think it's the bees' knees.  If
you use the prop types package,
this probably looks familiar toe
you.  In prop types, you have to
declare your types.  You get
more help from the compiler.
You don't have to include the
prop types package.  All of this
gets stripped out at compile
time, and you ship a smaller
bundle, a little bit.  So just
to walk through this, we have
our props.  We're going to have
one prop called size that
accepts small, medium, or large.
And then we just pass it into
our component as usual.  And you
can see here that inside my
component, I have very little
TypeScript-specific syntax.  It
really looks pretty much like
normal JavaScript.  And this is
what it looks like to use that.
I import my icon component, and
if I don't give props,
TypeScript will complain because
I told it to expect props.  Here
if I give it size, it can
suggest to me what the props
should be.  This is nice when
you're using a design system,
because you can know exactly
what the values are supposed to
be.  This is the VS code
interface, and when you run the
compiler, it gives this exact
suggestion where it will list
what it's expecting.  If I give
it something that it's
expecting, it will be happy and
I can compile my code.  I hope
that has made TypeScript a
little less mysterious.  Thank
you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Hello? Hey. Andy was
right on the dot on that timer.
Our next speaker is
[ Applause ]
>>Burke, and he's going to be
talking about, it's titled "the
best UX is no UI at all."
>> Has it started yet? What
do I do? Just go
to the right?
Again? Wrong slides.  Wrong
slides.  Different slides.
These are good slides, though.
[ Laughter ]
Should I tell a joke while
we wait? I don't know any jokes!
Help me out.
Let's see.  A good book is like
a puppy.  Easy to pick up; hard
to put down.  See, I told you I
didn't know any good jokes.  You
forced me into it! I didn't want
to do it!
Please hurry.  Okay.
All right! Did we start?
Thank you! That's it.  I'm done.
Can I go? Did I already start?
Tell me when to start? Now?
Okay.  Hi.  My name is Burke,
and I love user interface.  I
have always loved user
interface.  I remember staring
at the glory that was compact
tab works while I played this
game called the incredible
machine and listened to the
tears for fears greatest hit
album.  I was listening to mad
world way before Donny darko and
that creepy rabbit movie.
That's an old and obscure
reference.  It's not you.  It's
me as Costanza would say.
That's another old and on secure
reference.  I got my first
computer when I was in boot
camp.  They pay you but you
can't spend it because you're
doing push-ups.  I got my first
computer -- oh, you can see the
slides right here -- which was
an HP pavilion.  It came with
windows 98.  My sounds aren't
working.  There we go.  I loved
windows 98.  I spent so much
time changing the different
themes, looking at the icons and
the text.  Each theme was better
than the previous theme.  It was
incredible.  It was so good! And
if only I had known then, if
only I had known what was
coming, if only I had known
about windows XP... okay.
This was -- do you believe
in love at first sight? Does it
exist? No, of course it doesn't.
Don't be ridiculous.  It's a
complex human emotion.  Let me
tell you what does exist.
Infactuation.  I was infact
--
I was infactuated with XP.  I
was not socially popular, so I
had time to sit around and stare
at operating systems.  When you
can do that, you want to make it
look like OS10.  So this
goes out to you.  As much as I
love UI, I'm not a designer.  As
much as I want to be a designer,
I am not.  What I can do is
assemble building blocks.  If
you give me sliders and
drop-downs and modal windows,
then I can build you a UI.  I
used to work for a company
called Kendall UI, and I have
been fortunate to be part of
great products.  But you
wouldn't hire me to build a
website for you.  Unless you're
my mom.  If you did, you would
get sub par results.  What I
realized through all of my time
working with UI, is that the
best user experience is no UI at
all.  So let me talk about that
for a second.  UI is a middle
man.  It's a conversation.  It's
pre-canned.  It has boundaries.
We try to code for the simplest
possible scenario to get a user
through the process, or all the
processes in the world! Right?
And so we could improve upon
this UX probably a little bit.
There's been great feats of UXG.
If a baby can pick up an iPad
without training, that's kind of
an amazing thing.  The reason we
have UI and wonderful buttons
and sliders is historically, we
haven't been able to talk to
computers -- until now.  Natural
language processing is the field
of computing that deals with not
just speech recognition but
extracting a user's intent from
what they just said.  We have
Alexa, Cortona, Google home,
okay Google or Google assistant
or whatever you call that thing.
A lot of people have these.  I
will give you three examples of
how no UI is better than a UI.
I can say hey siri, remind me to
e-mail my mom.  That experience
is way better than this.  No
matter how beautiful the
reminders app is, it will never
be easier than saying just do
it.  Here is an example of me
turning lights on and off.
Here's the app that you do it
with.  Here's me turning lights
on and off with the app.  Very
nice.  Here's me
doing it...
Alexa, turn off the lights in
the master bedroom >> Now
watch this.
>> Okay.
>> Alexa, can you turn on the
bedroom -- turn on the master
bedroom lights.
>> Okay.
>> That is natural language
processing.  It completely
botched that command seven
different ways and it was able
to do it.  If you have a nest
thermostat, you can lay in bed
and control your temp with your
voice.  Now that I said that,
its sounds pathetic.  Never
mind.  I don't ever do it.
The last I would give you is
a service called digit.  It
saves for you and it will give
you savings updates.  I blurred
this out so you don't get too
depressed by my lowball lance.
-- low balance.  It was
resilient at understanding my
commands.  I didn't have to know
what to say, I just said it.  So
the question now is, is UI as we
know it dead? The answer is no.
No! Absolutely not.  There are
accessibility concerns.  You
wouldn't want to take photos
with your voice or scroll
through pictures with your
voice.  That's not a good user
experience.  But it does give us
a chance to rethink some of the
ways that we build UIs that
maybe we don't need to build a
UI, and instead what we need to
build is something that's more
conversational in nature that
uses natural language
processing.  That's now
available to all of us.  And if
I'm going to end a little early.
You can check out
the project here.  As long as
you know how to make an AJAX
call, you can add natural
language processing to your
applications and build a BOT or
a conversational UI.
Thank you so
much.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you. I just want to
acknowledge my co-Emcee.  We use
they/them pronouns.  I don't
really know the name yet.  We're
going to be friends in a
minute.
Their name is
Beyla.  Our next talk is Istvan
and his talk,
2,506 bytes ought to be enough
for anyone.  Thank you so much.
My Iceland.  dear co-presenter
is going to
>> be here today, Beyla. You
can see them
holding yeast yesterday's beer.
We will be talking about 2,560
bytes is probably enough for
anyone.  If you don't get this,
you are probably not very old.
I am from Hungary, or at least
from I rent an apartment there.
I'm a speaker.  I worked with
the dev team doing the same
thing, and I'm doing a bunch of
JavaScript,
microcontroler stuff, and
the T
Tessel project brought me into
programming to begin with.  I
started playing around with it,
and I did my first presentation
in Budapest on JavaScript and
microcontrolers and convincing
people that running JavaScript
on a microcontroler might be a
good idea, or at least not a
terrible idea.  Why would that
be? I'm not sure this talk is
going to sell it to you.  But
one of the creators, John McKay,
has given a talk last year
talking about the whole journey
of the Tessel team.  It's
fascinating how they use
JavaScript on a microcontroler.
There are devices like you see
on the screen.  This is the
thing that you see is a USB
connector.  And you can program
this with JavaScript.  It had a
very strange JavaScript
compiler.  Somebody didn't think
it was okay, so they set out to
bring JavaScript properly on to
microcontrolers.  It has
improved a lot.  Espruino is a
capable chip by now.  It powers
a lot of devices.  You can power
BBC microbits on it.  It is
interesting stuff happening, and
I forgot to set this up, so let
me just set some -- hopefully --
yep.
Not yet.  Technical
difficulties, I guess.  Let me
see if I can get this
to work.
There you go.  Now we're
talking.  All righty.  Let's
talk about a bunch more
interesting stuff like
JavaScript.  Babel announced
they were running JavaScript on
their watches, and they didn't
stop until they could get
JavaScript running and
efficient.  230 lines of code
versus 39 lines of JavaScript
over the UI of a smart watch.
And when they went defunct last
year, they got bought out by fit
bit, and my watch is running
JavaScript on the UI.  You can
create apps for your watch on
JavaScript.  But we need to get
smaller.  These are pretty
capable chips.  How about
putting JavaScript on a
microcontroler like this? Have
you ever played with this
before? This is an 8 bit
processor.  It literally has
2,56 o
bytes of memory.  It holds 30K
of flash.  And you can do stuff
like put space invaders on it.
How? There are bunches of way.
Usually you use some C
+ + to code it.  It's a good
thing, and you just mentioned
flow.  It uses flow to infer
your types and stuff.  I don't
have time to explain it.  But
come up to me and try it
yourself.  Because that's all
the games you will be make
willing be just JavaScript, you
can just put them on to the web
and play them.  And after you
played them, you can compile
them and put them on to devices
like this one.  This is a
JavaScript game running on a
microcontroler, with hardware
that has 8 bit 16 megaHertz
processor.  Or you can use this
one.  It's a tiny arcade box
that you can play with.  Why is
that interesting? Because this
is just JavaScript as you are
writing.  And you can check
that, because I have some links
up.  If you go to this with your
computer or laptop, actually,
you can play the exact same game
that gets compiled down to the
microcontroler.  And we have
space invaders if you're into
that kind of stuff.  And we have
a workshop.  So if you're
Icelandic or going to be driving
around the island in the next
week, drop by the university
next Saturday, and we're going
to do a whole workshop with the
creators of these devices were
kind enough to provide us with a
bunch of devices.  So you can
play JavaScript games and put
them on to a microcontroler
and play around.  If you want to
talk to me about this stuff, hit
me up on Twitter or follow me.
All of this is open source.
Most is built on node.js and
compiler.  You can contribute if
you want to.  All the slides are
online.  That's an Icelandic
domain, right? Thank you very
much.  There's a reading list,
if you want to know more about
the talks.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you. Our next talk
is from Martin, and he's going
to be talking about accessible
customizable selects, and it's
probably harder than you
thought.
>> Hi. Okay. This is
working? Great.  Welcome to my
presentation about accessible
customizable select.  My name is
Martin, and I work as a
front-end developer for a
company.  Let me address the
elephant in the room.  Why
another JavaScript? Isn't it the
first rule that we should always
use the native whenever
possible? True.  However, the
native thought is hard to style
using CSS.  This forces us to
create our own custom
implementations, and we need to
reimplement the accessibility
into it as well.  And I'm not
talking about high enough
contrast and large enough fonts.
What I mean
is supporting assistive
technologies, such as the screen
readers used by the visually
impaired.  And there must be
plenty of existing solutions out
there? Well, I have looked
into them.  I have reviewed
existing solutions provided by
various companies and various
techniques.
Unfortunately, there were
issues.  For example, the
implementation provided by
Google as part of the polymer
project is not compatible with
JAWS and square key when using
voiceover screen readers.  How
can we use such a solution? We
cannot.  On the other hand,
there's implementation by Jquery
UI, which is buggy and remains
completely silent when used with
voiceover.  So how can we use
such a solution? We
cannot.  We were looking for a
solution that could be
integrated into any project
regardless of its front end
technology.  But of course,
accessibility was the top line
priority.  What do I mean? We
were looking for a solution that
works regardless of the
operating system the user may be
using.  With slight reservation
when it comes to Linux,
assistive technologies is not as
great as it's going to be.
Next, we must support all of the
commonly used browsers,
including internet explorer 11.
If the technologies used by the
solution would be available for
up to I8.  Support for all major
screen readers used around the
world is a must.  And of course,
we cannot forget about the
myriad of keyboard shortcuts.
Don't worry.  We don't have to
consider all of these
combinations and all of these
technologies equally, since
there are combinations that are
recommended by the providers and
vendors of these assistive
technologies.  It doesn't mean
we can ignore the rest.  We just
need to make sure that these
work really well.  On the other
hand, there are combinations
that are just not compatible at
all.
For example, the JAWS screen
reader is incompatible with the
Edge browser.  I'm told this is
being fixed.
All of this has taken us on
several months of a journey in
which we were testing and
prototyping, and we made quite a
couple of findings.
Accessibility supporting
browsers could be improved.  And
support for aria, which is used
to make our websites more
accessible is implemented by
assistive technologies, not
browsers, inconsistently.  This
makes situations where you are
prototyping and testing a
solution.  It seems to work fine
with one assistive technology.
And things completely break
apart.  After a moment, you will
begin to feel like Alice in
wonderland.  Things just don't
make any sense.
This is me right here.
Anyway.  There are some positive
sides about this.  For example,
once you put accessibility into
the mix, the Android and iOS
platform are pretty much the
same.  Throughout all of this, I
have been reminded of a quote by
Steve Jobs.  Yes, he's more
handsome than me.  Great things
are never done by one person in
business.  They are done by a
team of people.  Similarly, to
achieve great accessibility, we
cannot rely on just a single
technique.  We will need to find
a combination of techniques that
will work well together.  Well,
have we found such a solution?
I'm happy to tell you that,
indeed, we have.  We were able
to design a solution that adapts
and works very well with all the
compatible combinations of these
major technologyes.  The project
itself is MIT-licensed, open
source, available at GitHub,
where you will find more
detailed project information,
current documentation, and how
you may integrate this into any
of your projects regardless of
the technology you may be using.
Thank you, and I wish you a nice
day here in
Iceland.
[ Applause ]
>> That's our first half of the
lightning talks.  We will have a
break for ten minutes, and come
back for more later.
Thank you.  Iceland.
[ Applause ]
>> That's our first half of the
lightning talks.  We
[ Applause ]
[
Break ]
Live Captions by:
@smiley845 with @whitecoatcapxg
>> Hey, everyone. Welcome back.
We're going to be talking about
hacking the future with Laurens.
>> Hi. I'm at the university
of applied sciences at
Amsterdam, but that's not what
I'm here to talk to you about
today.  I'm a volunteer at a
refugee code school called hack
Your Future.  While I can tell
you what that is, but it's been
done better in this
video.  I'll show you a short
clip.
[ Video ]
.
[ Music ].
>> Hack your future is an
initiative.
>> It's an organization. that
is especially for refugees.
>> That come to the Netherlands.
I think it's mostly Syria, but
other places as well.
>> People who have left their
countries involuntarily to pick
up a new skill, hopefully.
>> So hack your future teaches
them computer programming, web
development.
>> CSS and HTML. And you
learn basics and JavaScript, of
course.
>> And help them to find
jobs.
>> These are people who had
some unfortunate circumstances,
perhaps, and are trying to do
something good for themselves
and for the world.
>> I'm proud of myself that I
could learn it.
>> So this actually tells you
about what hack your future is.
But not so much about why hack
your future is.  So hack your
future was founded by a couple
of people who thought, well,
there's a growing group of
refugees coming to our country.
And they actually have a lot of
trouble entering the job market
because they won't have the
right backgrounds.  They'll have
language barriers.  Maybe
there's discrimination issues
going on.  How can we prevent
these people from becoming
marginalized in our society.  So
they funded hack your future,
because they decided what's the
best way to empower people and
the best way to get them jobs:
One of the best ways is to teach
them web development skills.
There's a lot of demand for web
development skills.  It allows
you to go into various different
paths, as you all know.  We
thought, well, how can we do
that? We came up with an idea of
setting up a volunteer program
where volunteers teach refugees
every Sunday for about four
hours.  We have interactive
sessions with them.  And then
they spend about 20 hours
working on home work
assignments.  And they hand in
their homework on GitHub.  And
we interact with them throughout
with week on Slack.  So they
have support for the whole week.
We teach them basic skills.
First we start off with HTMLHTML
CSS, because they have virtually
no technical skills coming in,
and that's an easy way to enter
the field.  Then we spend nine
weeks on the basics of
programming through JavaScript,
which I had a lot of pleasure in
teaching them.
They're super-motivated, so it
goes faster than with my
students at the university.  And
after -- at the end of those six
months, they work on a project
and they actually develop
something themselves.  They
often choose to develop
something that will benefit
other refugees, which is really
awesome.  And alongside that
program, we also teach seminars
on how to conduct yourself in
job interviews.  How to make a
good LinkedIn profile, you know?
Basic skills that you might also
want, and things that are quite
different in the Netherlands as
opposed to, for instance, Syria.
So yeah, that's the way that we
set it up.  So what have we
achieved? We have about 55
students that have found jobs at
companies such as KPMG,
booking.com, and KLM.  I guess
that's the main thing that we've
achieved.  But we also have an
active network of students, men
20Rs,  -- mentors and alumni.
They're all in the Slack group,
and they help each other out
with anything from finding good
companies to apply it, to how to
cycle through the snow in the
Netherlands when winter comes.
And we've also achieved 100% up
time for the past two years, and
who can really say that about
any program they're running.  We
also have new chapters in
Copenhagenen, London, and more.
People have started copying our
project.  Hopefully it leads to
a better future.
So I also have a quote.
It's not by Steve Jobs.  It's by
one of our students, Jack.  He
says that his main take-aways
from the program were to -- how
to think like a programmer, how
to work in a team, and most
importantly, that people can
still treat him for the person
that he is and not the way that
he might be seen.  Which I think
is a very important thing for
these students coming to us,
because as soon as they enter
our doors, they stop being a
refugee and they start being a
student.  We just treat them
like that, and we don't really
talk about their backgrounds at
all.  We treat them as students
and we say this is your
homework.  You have to deliver
on it.  We will be supportive
and try to help you with any
issue, but you have to deliver.
So, actually, the point of
this talk is not to tell you how
awesome it is that I work at
this program, that I volunteer,
or how good this program is.  I
actually want all of you to
start copying this idea, and to
set up a hack your future of
your own.  I think it's one of
the best ways to empower people.
So how can you do that? You'll
need a couple of ingredients.
First off, a convenient
location.  It's important that
people can actually reach your
location.  And a lot of these
people will be in camps, and
they might not have a lot of
money or means of
transportation.  So that's
important that you find a good
location.  Secondly, you'll need
some laptops.  They don't need
to be start of the art.  It's
better if developers don't have
state of the art laptops so they
learn to develop for old people.
You'll need a program director,
or better yet, a team of people
prepared to think about the hard
challenges that you might face
to get everybody together.  We
can help you a bit with that.
You'll need mentors, and it
seems like it might be difficult
to find people to volunteer,
especially on a Sunday.  But
we've found that there's an
abundance of mentors.  People
are happy to help.  There are
people from universities.
There's people from companies.
There's people from any place
you can think of.  A lot of
people with diverse backgrounds
like to help out as well.  So we
have a very diverse group of
mentors helping out.  And
students, of course.  This is
the most important part.  It
might not be as easy as finding
the mentors, because you need to
find people that have basic
English skills, first.  That's
our minimum requirement.  But we
also want them to be very
motivated.  So we actually have
them do a little test before
they're allowed to join our
program.  And it's about
learning a skill on your own.
So they have to prove that they
can do that within a certain
amount of time.  And it's a task
that really anybody can
complete, as long as they're
motivated.
I guess a lot of people will
ask, how do you get financial
support? You don't need that
much money.  It's nice if some
companies help out and donate
old laptops.  It's nice in the
municipality helps out with the
rent a bit or gets you a
location.  But ultimately, this
is definitely something that you
can overcome.  You would be
surprised at how many people
want to help if you have a good
idea.
Of course you also need a
curriculum.  This is something
that can be very difficult to
set up, but we've already done
it for you.  So I'll show you a
link on our curriculum.  It's
just something on GitHub.  It's
just a list of topics that we
think is good to talk about.
But of course you can set up
your own way of doing it.  So,
how would you do this? Just
like JSConf, you can say I like
this idea and I want to do it in
my city.  So you fork the
project, and if you want to know
how to get started, you
go to start code school, and
there will be lots of tips and
documents and a set-up for a
code of conduct.
There will be an article about
how to deal with students who
have some trouble with staying
in the country.  There will be
some tips on how to conduct
yourself as a teacher.  So, we
strive to share all of the
knowledge that we already have
here.  And we also have links to
all of the resources that we
use.
If you need some more help,
you can talk to me on Slack.  I
think there should be a space
between Laurens and Aarnoudse,
which is a very dutch name.  I
will be around for these two
days, and I like to work
together with you and to create
a better future.  Thank
you.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you so much for that
talk.  I hope someone -- I don't
know, maybe me can bring that to
New York.  That would be
awesome.  Anyway, our next talk
is from Kristjan.  He's going to
be talking about something cool
that GitHub
could do.
>> Hello. Oh my God, I can't
see my speaker notes.  That's
fine.  Hey.  I work at GitHub,
but this talk isn't about me as
an engineer at GitHub.  It's
more of a
user.  Before I started at
GitHub, I would have these ideas
like, I wish GitHub could do
this one thing.  And I would
write Chrome extensions to do
these things.  But there's some
things -- there they are!
There's some stuff that I
couldn't do as Chrome
extensions.  For those things,
I've recently discovered this
library.  This is not the right
clicker.  There you go.  It's
called pro BOT, and it's a
library for GitHub to write
these GitHub applications.  And
pro BOT does this by leveraging
web hooks and the GitHub API to
give you the power to extend
guilt hub in a
-- GitHub in a simple way.  If
something happens to GitHub,
proBOT gets a ping, and it will
analyze what to do in the
situation, and maybe fire off
events of its own.  I have a
little trivial example.  If we
want to respond to every issue
opened in our repository, and
let's just say hello.  A
welcoming message.
We're going to build it right
now.  We have this module, and
it takes in probot as an
argument or parameter.  We can
attach event listeners on the
robot.  There's a list on the
GitHub documentation page for
what you can listen to.  You're
listening to if there's any
events opened.  We get this
context with it.  With the
context, we can create a
comment.  This is kind of
confusing, and I didn't
understand this at first.  But
it just gives you an object back
that operates in the context of
this issue.  And we just give it
the body for the issue.  And
then just using GitHub API, it's
easy.  Create this comment.  We
can run this.  And every time
someone opens up an issue where
this probot is installed, it
will respond, thanks for
the issue.  There's a bunch of
these BOTs out there.  Sometimes
they will close down the issues
when nobody has commented the
issue.   for some days, and I
have a problem that I really
want it to solve with probot.
And it is related to ES lent.
I don't know if everybody here
uses it, but I almost always use
it.  It will run in a build.
And if someone broke an ES lent
rule, it will give you like a
red status.  There's just one
problem with this: People can
just disable the rules right
there in the code.  So this is a
project that I have where
somebody disabled the rules and
did whatever they wanted.  I
understand that people need to
get stuff done.  They're like, I
don't know how to do this.  I
know how to use JQuery show.  I
don't know how to show and hide
things.  I maybe would want it
to focus that you shouldn't do
this.  Or, like, ping me and I
can explain how to do it
correctly.  So, like, this
previous one, it just goes
through and everything is green,
people
are great.  I, like I said, I
would like for these to be
flagged.  So I wrote this
probot.  I gave it a logo.  It's
an ESLint logo with the eyes
emojiemoji.  When a pull request
comes in, it checks the diff,
and if disable is in there, it
will comment on there.  There's
a great thing.  If you install
probots into your repositories,
you can give conflicts.  My
probot, you can change this
message.  If you wanted to give
him like a little image, you can
do that.  You can @ the team
that should review this.
Like @the JS team.  And if
they're like legitimate
ESLint disables.  This talk went
really fast.  You can find
probot on my GitHub, which is up
there.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> That's actually all of our
lightning talks for today.  So
I'm here to say that y'all can
leave early.  But I'm also here
to promote the party happening,
and I
[ Applause ]
>> That's actually all of our
lightning talks for today.  So
hope I can pronounce this right.
At
Egisgarour.  I tried.
It's in your leaflet.
And also, until around 6:30,
there's going to be a bus coming
in from here, and also the hotel
to the party.
And dinner is also provided.  So
don't, you know, have dinner
before the party, unless you
want to have a second dinner,
which I won't judge.  And Harpa
opens tomorrow at 9:00.  I hope
you enjoyed the rest of your
day.  That's it.